Hey
Adam,
how are you buddy?
I'm doing good.
Rally Self.
Good man.
I'm on top of them.
Thank you so much for having me on man.
I was a big fan of the show and not just a friend so I love coming on here dude.
We've known each other a long time and I was getting weird getting weird and can
wear and we're getting on there and the one that I always brag about like how
cool was where because you were busy as shit when you did the culture high cause
everybody always asks being,
you know fans of the show,
they're like man Romans seems so cool.
I'm like you came to Edmonton to do that.
You're doing your shell.
It was after your show pack show at the the river Cree and then we started the
interview at like 11 we didn't get done until one 30 in the morning.
Then you had to fly out in the morning.
Yeah it was what,
a couple hours later I will leave.
You know,
like I just think your fans to know how cool it is that you,
you do so much to try to help other people.
I'm really appreciate it man.
That took the time and,
and did that when crazy you flew in that day,
did your show,
went for dinner,
came afterwards,
bust out two and a half hours and flew home a couple hours later.
I think that's really cool man.
Oh well thanks man.
This is not that hard.
Just talking.
Yeah,
but you know how to talk.
I can do that.
But the,
the documentary was really good man.
Cultural hose you got,
I mean I was wondering,
I was like,
man,
where are they going to take it?
Cause you guys covered so much of marijuana prohibition in the Union.
There's two documentaries that I'm was done.
Uh,
the union,
which is all about BC and uh,
what's going on in British Columbia as far as the economy,
which is just inexorably wrapped up in the cannabis market.
It's really kind of crazy.
The world of British Columbia,
like literally the economy of there would kind of implode if pot went away.
Well that's it.
Like they compare like tourism is number one and then it was like a close second
because how do you determine exactly the black market money is,
but it was in the estimates were not being questioned at the five to seven to $9
billion range of the black market of the marijuana industry.
We're hate so much weed,
so much being shipped.
And majority of it at that time was going to the United States,
right?
Yeah.
So we looked at that because originally the reason we did the union and looked
focused so much on the BC industries,
I looked at getting into it,
I came back from New York and all the guys that like I went to school with and
stuff,
we're growing and we're doing really well.
They had nice new houses,
new Harley's living on the lake,
and that's what even where the name,
the union came up from when I was like,
dude,
what the fuck is he been doing?
He's doing really well.
And I'm like,
man,
he's in the union.
I'm like,
which one?
I want to sign up.
And they're like,
he grows dope.
And I'm like,
oh,
that's how he's making his money.
So well that that first documentary we was really fascinating and it puts you
guys on the map and it took a while before you decided to do another one on pot.
But like I was like,
where are they going to come up with other shit?
Talk about did you covered everything so thoroughly?
Well thank you.
We were the same problem.
Like Brett was really stressed about that.
The director,
like he was just like,
man,
he's like,
I thought I did it all in the union.
Like what?
What?
What can I do?
But the fans really wanted another one.
Like when you had me on the last time we were doing the Kickstarter campaign and
we were just receiving thousands of messages and everybody's,
you got a new,
another
one,
you got to do another one.
So Brett really dove into,
as you saw a human culture and politics,
right.
And then kind of fitting.
We went big into looking at the,
how policing has changed in our culture because of the drug war where one of the
biggest assets that police had his information to prevent new crimes.
But something that's happened almost strictly because of the drug war,
because of the way that the ratting system goes.
Like,
Hey,
we catch you for minor possession and you've already got parole.
You give us the bigger guys and we'll abolish your thing and you won't go to
jail.
Well people saw their brothers,
cousins,
mothers,
family members getting arrested for simple possession and serving two to three
years that they were like,
well I don't want to talk to the police anymore.
So when a violent crime happens,
rape,
murder or something really heinous,
you don't want to talk to the cops cause you're like,
he might start grinding on me for simple drug possession or something like that.
Right.
And the cops we interviewed said like during their career,
they specifically witnessed the change,
like in the beginning of their career when they're in their 20s they go through
communities and people would come up to them and want to see their badge and
take a picture and see their handcuffs.
And it was like cool.
By the end of their career they would drive down neighborhoods and nobody wanted
to talk to them.
Right.
Because it just felt that they're warring on us.
It's US versus them versus being,
you know,
serving and protecting the community.
Wow.
That's fucked.
The,
the,
the scene where the guy has his dog shot or the cops break into his house and
there was nothing there.
I mean he had like paraphernalia.
They found a pipe with resin,
shoot his dog,
his little kids.
I mean you and I both have kids.
Like could you imagine people coming in your house like shooting your dog in
front of you and it was a little yappy dog.
Yeah.
It wasn't like some fucking where rottweiler or something like that.
It was just,
it's so sick because they do it to intimidate the people and to let the people
know they mean business and because they can,
you know.
You know that story about the mayor who lives outside of DC,
they accidentally did this to him.
Yes,
I heard about that.
Yeah,
those have been a good store.
I was wondering if you were going to cover it in the documentary.
It's a crazy story for folks who don't know about it.
This guy,
apparently the postman was having pot shipped to this house because he knew that
this was on his route,
so he would just intercept it and so like he knew that the package was from his
friend,
so he would,
he would look at all the packages that came to this guy's house and because it
was in a nice area,
a lot of people wouldn't question it.
Well,
somehow or another,
the DEA got wind of this.
They realized that a package was coming to this guy's house and so they just
decided to ray the dude's house.
They kick in the door,
waving the full for all you heard was,
papa don't hit me.
No think they should.
They shoot the guy's dog.
And then they ran out.
They had labs,
you know,
like would you like the friendliest dog ever?
Ever.
The dog ran out into the yard to hide and they went and found him and shot him.
You know,
I mean,
they allow the two shot,
two dogs and then they zip tied the family.
Um,
and this guy was a fucking my hair,
you know,
and he's like,
oh,
you can't,
I can't believe,
but it's kind of good for it.
Not for the dogs,
obviously to get shot.
But for a guy like that to see like this is what happens when you're a regular
person.
If they don't know you,
you know,
they don't know about your relationship with city hall or any of that nonsense.
They just,
this is how they treat you.
If they can.
Well,
and then you can imagine if you're from a lower economic situation right now,
you're stuck in the legal system.
Good luck.
Right?
And trying to get out of that and fight your way out.
You are looked at as a criminal from day one,
even if you're innocent and we go deep into the asset forfeiture laws in the
film too,
right,
where they take everything in certain states and then you have to prove that
they didn't have the right to take in the first place,
that that wasn't proceeds of crime.
Right.
Go in and take.
It's funny cause that opening scene like people are shocked by it,
but I've read,
received a lot of people that were really like huge as they are so mad,
they're like,
that was not needed in the film.
It's ridiculous.
I stopped watching.
As soon as you put it there and oh,
they're babies.
They need to realize this is what's going on and you're doing a documentary on
disturbing things.
You want to leave out the disturbing things from the documentary and disturbing
things.
Exactly like in the theater when you watch it with a crowd,
which is always my favorite part is a filmmaker.
When you can really see it having an impact.
And you see the audience right there that wakes everybody up,
the credits come in and it's like boom,
that happens.
And everybody's like,
Oh shit.
Okay we're going on a ride here.
Right?
Yeah.
That's,
well it's awful rod.
You know that that really hurts my feelings.
I want and that's a,
that's hard to deal with.
That asset forfeiture laws really fucked too.
There's a guy who was a store owner and a,
he had made apparently made too many deposits that were less than a $10,000 in
cash and they accused him of,
you know,
I guess they have some,
some thing called structuring or something like that.
And the idea of being like,
oh I'll pull this uh,
image or the uh,
the story rather.
Cause it was a,
it's kind of a fucked up story man.
Cause this guy was just a store owner.
I mean he,
there's no evidence whatsoever that this guy has done anything wrong.
I mean he's doing all these interviews in his store.
He would take some of the money from his store.
You know,
I don't know if you put it in a safe or whatever and he would get up to you
know,
eight thousand nine thousand bucks and just go deposit it in the bank.
Thought there was no big deal.
The Dea came in and just stole all of his fucking money,
like literally stole all of his fucking money and now this guy is stuck and now
you have to go spend all the money to try to argue no more than they stole.
I'm sure you know it's crazy.
Well that's the part,
you know,
through both films that was so I think shocking for us is when you sit down with
all these ex law enforcement,
because in the culture I,
we sat down with Sean done again.
He was a former DEA analyst and you sit down with,
yeah,
you got it Jeremy.
That's it.
I just pulled it off of,
here's this gentleman seven.
He's a convenience store on us structuring policy.
So what does that,
if they see too many deposits just conveniently under $10,000 and they consider
it.
Yeah,
I mean,
but this guy,
he just owns a convenience store.
He gets cash.
I mean it's all right there.
It's all super obvious
and the guy's gone public with it all.
So it's a massive embarrassment for the IRS.
They're just,
it's just evil.
It's just the fact that they think that they can do this,
you know,
like there's no evidence whatsoever.
Suspicion of structuring is what they call.
And by the way,
that violates their own requirements.
It's not like they have,
they have like requirements that you have to meet in order for them to take the
money if they accuse you of structuring.
There has to be some evidence whatsoever,
but there's nothing and there's continuing to pursue.
It was the DEA is me getting hit hard lately cause you've seen Michelle
Lionheart step down,
right?
She's a fucking dummy.
Oh my God,
that lady so dumb.
Well that clip is so good.
I mean it's been all over,
but we use it in the culture high too,
right?
Where that guy just grills are right.
It's like all of his math bars for you to have marijuana.
All drugs are bad.
Again.
Again,
all drugs are bad.
That part he's so dumb.
It's amazing that that lady figured out a way to get that Gig.
She is so poorly equipped to discuss the nature of addiction and drugs in front
of the whole world.
Like that.
You could see her deer in the headlights look like,
did you fuck him prepare for this at all lady?
Well that's I think Jank in the film.
He does a great part where he explains,
he's like,
you know,
Obama could have picked anyone.
He's like,
why did he pick the most right wing or Republican?
cause then that way he'll see more moderate and it might help them to get votes
in the future.
And that's exactly what it is.
It's just he's really good at playing that stupid fucking politician.
Oh,
it's that line that Janky is in the film that I love and he's like,
and that's what people does.
Nobody gets about Obama.
He's a politician just like the rest of them.
Right.
Don't be mistaken.
There's no other way to get to that position where you're going to actually get
in the White House.
You're one of those two guys.
You know,
the commission for presidential debates is a privately owned institution.
People don't,
a lot of people don't know it.
Can you see those guys that are being,
uh,
there debating each other on television?
You figure like,
well,
those guys are the,
the most popular candidates.
This is not exactly,
you know,
the ones marketed correctly and have the money behind them.
Yeah.
You have to,
just in order to get into the commission for presidential debates to get into
the,
uh,
the debate,
you have to have 15%,
uh,
polling in five poles and they can choose those poles.
They can just go and rent,
decide this uses,
who chooses the people that run the commission for presidential debates,
which is owned by like some multinational corporations and does a bunch of bunch
of fuckery involved.
Well,
they let Ron Paul in,
or excuse me,
um,
the fuck's his name,
the old dude.
But Ross Perot,
Ross Perot,
Ross Perot fucked everything up for everybody.
And Ross Perot.
People don't remember.
Ross Perot,
who was this crazy Texas billionaire who,
um,
you know,
accused
essentially the IRS and the Federal Bank of,
of running this crazy pyramid scheme.
And you know,
I mean,
he was,
uh,
talking about the federal bank and the Federal Reserve long before anybody ever
understood that the Federal Reserve had nothing to do with federal,
I mean,
they call it the Federal Reserve.
It's like,
it's a privately owned company.
It's kind of hilarious that all of our money goes through that.
I mean,
the,
the hustle runs so deep and has been going on for so long,
but Ross Perot was this billionaire dot dude who this is pre internet.
And he bought out time on,
on television and put his own television show on and had like fucking charts and
graphs and showed where the money was going.
And everybody's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What?
Like he was the big,
he was like the first blip of this information,
uh,
that getting it out there to the public that is now like all over the Internet,
all over the Internet.
You know,
like people have this day and age like you taught you,
you could talk to the average 20 year old kid today and ask her like how the
Federal Reserve Works and I bet there's a lot of them that will go,
I'll tell you exactly how it works.
If you're dealt holy shit,
if you don't know exactly,
they're at least hip to it that it's a private corporation and there definitely
that access.
You guys talked about a lot here on the podcast,
but that access to information is change the game.
There's no more of those.
I used to call him toppers in high school that like whatever story you had,
like you had a cool story and they'd be like,
yeah,
well this one time I like whoa.
Like now you can be like,
okay,
so when were you there and you said you met such and such celebrity.
Well he wasn't there on those dates,
right?
He was touring like now you can call out that bullshit.
Yeah,
you could Snopes it.
Or like the urban legend that was,
you know when I was in high school was like that guy did so much acid.
He thought he was an orange or a banana and now he just just scared,
don't peel me,
don't peel me and now you Snopes and everybody's like,
no.
That's a common misconception of a guy that I'm sure maybe somewhere down the
road there was someone that thought something similar,
but that was like the scare story.
Urban legend that you'd heard what?
I was going to high school?
Yeah.
I didn't even find it.
I found out about Snopes through the rocket one where the guy like Patada rocket
to his car,
the truck and flew into a mountain and died.
I remember hearing about that and I was like,
what?
It was like one of those Darwin awards one,
but then it a Snopes was like,
Eh,
I don't think so.
It wasn't true when it might've been.
The thing about that is like,
you know for sure if someone has a rocket and someone has a car,
there's someone dumb enough to try a strap.
Those two things together and see what's up.
Like it's not outside the realm of possibility.
Absolutely not.
It's not saying like a guy went to the moon and you know,
found a Hubcap,
uh,
after hurting a nightclub for several years when I was younger.
I've seen tremendous amounts of stupid things happen,
especially when they're under the influence of alcohol.
You can't put it past what people will do every time you think you've seen it,
all a new one comes by and you're like,
uh,
okay,
now I've seen it all.
Well,
that's how the whole political system is capable of working in the first place
is because like,
people really are dumb.
They really,
you really can trick a good giant chunk of the people.
And we were talking about before,
but the commission for presidential debates,
um,
now it's because Ross Perot came in and fucked up everything and he's the reason
why Clinton
got elected in the first place over Herbert Walker Bush,
the old man Bush.
But now because of that,
it's like virtually impossible.
The jacked it up from 5% to 15%.
And you would have to spend,
they think that a conservative estimate is $250 million just in order to reach
15% in popular polls and like any popular polls and so to get five and r and
also they would have to pick those five like they could pick a few that you were
in in,
you know,
or that you didn't pull well in the go.
Oh No.
You know,
it's not like states that you definitely don't match with the,
the overall consensus.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's so,
it's just really weird that it's been so long and this hustle has been going on
for so long and no one like no one in the political system,
no one in like the Supreme Court or in Congress.
No one is stepping up to say,
hey,
why exactly do these guys get all this money?
But there's some weird people on the Supreme Court that are on deck for sure.
I actually started looking at it up from guests you've had on here that talked
about that and I started looking up some of those people.
I'm like,
are you kidding me that this guy's in a position of it
power?
Like that's fucking scary.
Oh,
Clarence Thomas,
you remember all that shit with him.
And then Anita Hill and the,
he was at the pubic hair and are coca cola and he was like a sexual harasser.
But that could have been bullshit too.
You know?
That's a good way to defuse somebody.
You know what I'm saying?
He's talking shit about,
you know,
sex in the office.
And I just think that we've reached this weird point where the age of
information and the old guard,
the way politics is always been done,
which is through deception and cronyism and Horse Shit.
It's like they're not compatible with each other because the age of information
is going to slowly but surely expose all these things and certain things.
Like,
I mean,
I firmly believe that the Internet is the primary reason why marijuana is legal
in Colorado.
Marijuana is legal in Washington DC.
Marijuana is legal and which is really kind of crazy when you think about it.
Yeah.
When it's changing all over the world like that.
Right.
And I would totally agree.
We put that in the culture high,
right?
Yeah.
That's the cause.
Now you know when politicians like w in the union,
we have that clip of Ronald Reagan and he's in that,
I don't know what press comment,
but he's like,
you know,
there's this new information and these sign on,
I'm,
you know,
surprise to the media hasn't made more available,
but they,
then they have,
but they believe marijuana can be the most dangerous drug that is in use in our
society today.
Remember,
it's that clip we have in our trailer.
Well nowadays you can literally be like,
okay,
I'm on Web MD.
Like what study you're referring to?
I'll look it up right now and you come to my own conformed conclusion.
But when he was doing those press conferences,
you're like,
hey,
this is a man of stature and power.
He's got information.
We're not privy to like Matt,
it is bad.
He's got scientists that know shit.
I don't.
Yup.
So now that's just pulled out of the woodwork like you see it in with Mitt
Romney,
we have some good clips of him where they kind of challenge him on things.
Right.
And like the old Barbara Bush of like just say no to drugs.
Like you know,
we show that scene with jade and David write 500 seizures a day and then he's
taking the non psychoactive CBD and now he's having one to two seizures a month,
which by the way is my friend's child as well.
Different a different kid.
But my friend's child did the exact same situation and it's working great for
him.
Fantastic.
His kid was having massive seizures all the time.
He moved up to Seattle so that he could get him on a CBD oil and now they're
gone.
Like the kid is much more engaging.
He talks,
he's like pretty severe autistic.
Yeah.
And that's something that with Jason,
he,
he's not sure how much was from the condition or how much was from the
medication that jade and took for,
you know,
the first seven years of his life,
he had over 25,000 pills.
Right.
A lot of them psychoactive pills.
And it's sad that your friend has to move to another state in order to get
something that is working.
We had a local girl in Colona to Kyla Williams that we did that we,
we did a screening there and we raised a whole bunch of money for and presented
a check for three grand and they came to the screening and the same thing,
they're fighting on the front line saying that because Canada has this real
hokey thing with it,
like it's federally approved due to a court case,
right,
where they said it's unconstitutional to deny people that are getting relief
from something.
Right.
So the Canadian feds have,
they dance around saying,
well we don't approve of it,
but if people are seeing benefits,
we can't prohibit them from getting it.
So you can get like a license in Canada that will make it anywhere across the
country that allows you to use it,
but they don't allow concentrates.
I'm like oils or edibles or anything like that.
So for Kyla who was only two or three at the time,
essentially they're saying she has to smoke it and her parents were like,
that's ridiculous.
Like we should be able to get the oil because that's considered a concentrate.
Right?
So they're like,
well no,
we're going to end.
Her grandfather was actually ex law enforcement and he said,
I'm going to break the law.
I used to think like everybody else cause I used to arrest when people would
bring up the marijuana medicinal argument as a law enforcement officer.
I'm like,
that's a bunch of hippy bullshit until it happened to my granddaughter.
Now I see what everybody was arguing about,
right?
And I'm going to fight just as hard so that my daughter can get access to safe
medical marijuana that works for her.
And she's responding tremendously.
Like she's got her life back.
She's focusing now.
Seizures are a big thing.
She's been seizure free.
That's great to hear,
man.
It's great to hear.
But it's,
it's sad to hear that it's so difficult to get,
it's sad to hear that it's,
it's such a complex issue,
but it's so simple.
I mean there's a plant,
it grows naturally and it's really good for you.
It's that simple at the end,
right?
And it has benefits and if you regulate it and control it,
like other products and studies have shown this is one of the most dangerous
plants ever observes as well.
I love all the dangers and strict nine.
Well,
they always bring in the the,
well,
that's where everyone laughs in the theater when you bring up the popcorn
analogy,
they're putting,
they're like,
yeah,
you know,
uh,
if you need a pound of salt,
you'll fucking die.
Right?
He's like,
but if you put a little bit of Po salt on popcorn,
it's actually quite good.
It tastes good,
right?
Like you can't,
like,
yes,
people can abuse
just about anything.
Yeah.
A pound of salt will fucking kill you.
You could go buy a pound of salt right now.
I mean,
any liquor store you go to,
you could drink yourself to death quite easily.
But we just go and just pick up a couple bottles of Jack Daniels and you're off
to the races.
It's over.
Former nightclub owner.
I've seen.
There's nothing more destructive than that stuff.
Nothing.
It's horrible.
It's horrible that that's our sanction drug.
Like we would have a totally different culture and the evidence is coming out of
Denver.
You look,
Denver has the lowest Dui rates they've ever recorded.
They have lower rates of assault and murder than they've ever recorded.
They have.
There's all these crazy numbers that are coming in and then the tax revenue is
off the charts.
They're making so much fucking money.
They have to give it back to the people and sadly that's the only thing that's
probably going to push.
A lot of other states are sad.
Sad though.
It's good.
No,
it's good.
It's good that it's happened.
It's sad that it's,
I always get scared when it's the wrong moral reason of why they're doing it.
Right.
That's the only reason.
And a politician he'll sell you on like,
well,
we want to help the people,
but it's really to make their pockets bigger.
Yeah.
I mean it is sad,
but that's the nature of the beast.
That's like getting angry at a whore that she sucked your Dick.
Now she wants money.
Thought it was good.
You were really moaning.
You probably enjoyed it.
Come on.
Good point.
We're not friends.
They're whores.
They're all politicians are horrors,
man.
I mean that's really what they do.
That's their,
their,
their job is to be fake and to get really good at being fake and figure out
where the tide is turning,
lick their finger and put it up and find out what that meant exactly.
We have you doing in the culture.
I right.
We're to,
we're going to go where the wind blows,
right?
We're going to go,
it's from my hunting experience actually with you.
Yeah.
You put powder in the air with when you hunt,
shoot to powder up in the air and it takes you where the wind,
we see the wing.
Yeah,
like baby shower.
It's like these little things.
You puff them in the air and it tells you which way the wind's blowing.
But I think that what's what's happening now with,
with information is because the fact that all the studies are out and all these
people that are involved in law enforcement have the opportunity to know someone
who is benefiting from it cancer or whether it's a people that have a severe
epilepsy,
whether it's autism,
there's so many different possible medical uses that could touch these people.
And so they become very skeptical.
Like one of my good friends,
he's a hardcore Republican,
he's really silly.
Like he's one of those dudes,
like he told me,
he's trying to tell me Obama was a Muslim guy.
We were at a party,
were to fucking laugh at that stuff from Canada.
I think that's really hilarious.
Obama is the biggest Muslim in the CALC I dude.
Right.
But this guy is,
his mom got sick and a stage four cancer and tr the CBD oils helped her
tremendously and now he's become this evangelist for it.
I mean he's still not engaging in an himself,
but he,
you know,
you could benefit from it.
It's like all the things that people don't want out a pot or one of the things
that pea potter good for.
Like this thing about like who don't want to lose control.
Like do you really do want to lose control?
You just don't know.
Like your ego has this fucking terrible grip on you and it's putting you in this
very confined way of looking at the world.
You have a very confined narrow gap that you're looking at the world through and
things like marijuana will open that gap up and allow you to,
to consider or reconsider your positions on all these things.
And that's one of the most terrifying aspects of it.
The politicians as well as to law enforcement because the idea that they'd been
wrong this whole time and they're going to somehow or another half to justify
all the different shit that they've done.
It's like once the cat's out of the bag like it is in Denver,
like it isn't Washington state,
that cat is going to get out of the bag everywhere.
Well,
and like you said,
the Internet is allowed where all those individual personal stories all over the
world can be shared in real time.
But you have HD on your phone,
right?
So you can film like Jayden or Jason did that with his son Jayden,
where he recorded like how the medication was working,
the pharmaceutical and like in real time like here's what it's doing.
He's now having tremors.
He's now having this from,
you know,
so and then you can put it on the Internet where other people can get informed
that you couldn't do that years ago.
Right.
It was like an urban myth way down the,
I heard it might work.
Right,
right.
Even we have a,
we have a,
a personal clip that's in the DVD,
extras of the culture that didn't make it in the film,
but it's about Dr. Lester Grinspoon,
right.
The First Ivy League doctor to start coming out with the real scientific
evidence to cannabis.
And he all did it on a bet to Carl Sagan.
They were best friends and Carl Sagan used to smoke three to four joints every
day and go work at NASA.
All law and discover,
hey,
some of the greatest theories to this day,
you've,
you've interviewed Neil,
the grass stayed like Carl Sagan is who everybody aspires to.
And Lester,
this is what's kind of funny about the stories.
He went to prove Carl Sagan wrong.
He said,
he's like,
I'm,
you know,
I'm a physician.
I am.
I'm from heart.
Like Carl,
that's just going to kill you.
And Carl Biko relax.
Lester have a puff flag.
It's not a big deal.
So Lester started looking into literature and started pulling it from all the
different universities and then realize that he'd been do,
he's like,
he be fucking kidding me.
I'm a Harvard professor and I was telling all these people and I was completely
wrong.
So then he wrote his first paper,
which Harvard totally tried to back out of and they didn't want to give him his
professorship of marijuana reconsidered.
And then he wrote marijuana,
the forbidden medicine.
And then just as fate would have it,
his son,
Danny gets diagnosed with leukemia at 11 years old and he's ashamed of himself
at the time that he didn't.
He's going through the regular treatments or the oncologist going through the
Chemo and everything and his daddy was getting really sick and the nausea
affected his son more than anything,
right.
His kid would be terrified for a week in advance of how sick he was going to
get.
And finally another physician was like,
well Lester,
I read your stuff.
Have you tried cannabis?
Like the stuff for anti nausea seems to be amazing and the science is there.
And he was like,
well I don't want to upset Harvard.
And Danny's like too young.
And then here's the kind of,
the kicker of the story that's so funny is that they go to the very place that
prohibition supposed to keep it out of his mom and daddy just go themselves
cause they're willing to try it.
They've read his paper at the manuscript,
they go to the local high school,
right.
And Mrs Grinspoon and Danny asked their friends within 10 minutes they got the
weed,
smoked it,
and his,
his oncologist said like radar thing.
He's like,
what did you guys do differently with Danny?
He came in,
took his therapy left and actually ate a full six inch sandwich one.
Whereas usually he was puking for three or four days,
right?
He was actually able and Lester's like it gave my son an extra two years of life
cause he could battle the nausea and keeps them nutrition down.
It's those little wins with health that goes such a long way when you're in the
cancer thing,
right?
Like if you're able to eat a little bit of food and get a little bit of
nutrition and that little bit of nutrition helps your body to fight back on its
own,
on top of the medication.
And that's where people can get caught up on the other side where like it's the
cure,
it's the cure,
not the cure.
Right.
As we interviewed oncologists,
cancer is individual specific DNA specific,
gender specific.
So what might work for you might not work for somebody else,
but that doesn't mean that if it does work for someone,
that shouldn't be a viable option for them to use that it's unquestionably a
very effective treatment.
There's been many,
many peer reviewed studies that show that without a doubt,
cannabis has a positive effect on people with cancer,
whether it's helping them sleep.
That's another big one that gives people sleep,
which helps your immune system,
which helps your immune system fight off cancer.
There's,
and it helps inflammation,
which also helps your body fight a lot of stuff and inflammation.
There's just so many,
so many factors that it's just,
it's gross,
man.
It's gross.
It's gross that we're in this position where we actually have to debate this.
This is like you and me sitting down talking about the benefits of drinking
water,
water release,
but if you drink too much mineral water,
that water,
that water is what they should be.
Kids are on their fucking,
I just think it's,
it's a matter of time and hopefully we'll see it in our lifetime.
I'm still amazed that it's still illegal.
I mean,
I remember when I was a kid in high school,
I just think it was the dumbest fucking thing ever.
I couldn't imagine that it had some and I didn't even know the facts of it.
I mean,
all I knew was that like there was drugs and there was pot and pot just kind of
made you dopey.
But alcohol was legal.
And I remember like,
I remember the first time I ever got drunk,
I was at my friend's house and uh,
we were listening to like fucking the doors and led Zepplin Shit Drinking Jack
Daniels and I was like 14 I just never should have.
I've threw up in a cow is disgusting.
Every everything about it was completely disgusting.
But um,
I remember like the next day,
like there's horrible hangover.
It's pounding headache and thinking,
how the fuck is that legal?
Like you could just drink whatever you want.
It's not even like they distributed to you.
Like,
you know,
like if you go and you say you get a Adderall or oxycontin or some sort of
strong prescription drug there it comes in pill form.
It says take two pills,
they give you a bottle of Jack and they're like,
good luck.
Fuck.
Then.
Then they advertise it like it's the sexiest thing ever,
right?
Like it's beautiful
guys that are clean cut and girls that are smoking hot and you're having a drink
and everything's perfect.
As a former nightclub owner I can say it hardly ever looks like that.
It's messy,
sweaty like it's not.
When I see those commercial I'm like that's very funny.
I was like,
you should film in my bar a little bit.
It doesn't look like it at all.
I mean and I'm not anti alcohol.
It just,
it just staggers the imagination.
It really their will.
And here's the point I thought about when we were doing the union like as a
nightclub owner and it was a interesting self reflection that came through cause
I was on the other side of weed.
I was very anti when I was younger because I bought into all the bullshit and
when I owned a nightclub,
when I,
we started doing the union,
he started learning so much.
I remember like after interviewing norm stamper,
the former police chief of Seattle or Dr,
lesser like my mind,
it'd be spinning for two weeks.
I'm just like,
I can't believe this.
Like I started looking at everything different.
And then here I was a nightclub owner serving people booze that they want and
we're supposed to not overserve but if you find me a bar,
I will find you a time when they overserve.
Right.
Like people come up that I go on six shots.
You're like,
well no,
actually you're only supposed to order one per person so it can get all six
people to come to the table.
Please.
The only bar where they don't overserve Disneyland.
If a problem,
if you go to the Disneyland Hotel,
the strict as fuck.
Like I tried to order four drinks,
they wouldn't even give it to me.
I'll give you two drinks at a time.
You're like,
what?
Like a shot and a beer.
That's it.
You know,
I don't even know if they have shots.
I think they were like mixed drinks.
That makes sense.
But that's Disneyland.
But I'm not surprised.
But when at the bar when we had it,
like I thought about like,
you know,
and you've seen it too.
I've ever talk about like,
you know,
seeing the odd bar fight and stuff.
And then when something like that happen,
I put it back to if it was in prohibition days.
Right.
Like a fight happens,
the guy gets knocked out really bad.
Well,
if it was during the days when you weren't supposed to be serving alcohol,
I can just imagine what they did with the severely injured guy.
They probably just threw him up the street and said like,
call an ambulance so it's not anywhere near us.
Otherwise we go down,
where's it at least now,
like you know,
yes,
there's problems associated with alcohol.
There's almost nothing we're going to do in society that's not going to have
some kind of problem or social aspect where we're going to have to adapt and
make sure it works perfectly.
Right.
Particularly alcohol particularly.
Yeah,
like I'm not anti alcohol.
Neither am I at,
I used to serve it.
How can I sell it and make a profit,
but it is the number one drug when it comes to like social problems,
domestic violence.
There's so many different things go wrong when people drink and it's everywhere.
And the idea that somehow know that they've been able to demonize marijuana,
which has the complete opposite effect.
Show me a group of potheads that are in getting engaged in gang violence,
beating each other up.
They're meeting in the fucking park and duking it out.
Good.
You're not going to,
I mean,
show me a bunch of people that are smoking pot that are,
you know,
running around getting him Barb,
pot bar fights.
It doesn't,
isn't it?
It's the opposite is the end.
It was something that I,
I witnessed organically when I was going through the discovery with the union
like that.
Cause at that time I owned the Bar,
right?
So I'd see every weekend it was like fight someone dry and it was crazy
about booze.
The effect it has on people sometimes like people will fight their friends,
they'll get drunk and like all of a sudden I'm like,
dude,
you guys are best friends and now you're willing to strike him in the face just
because you're a little drunk.
Like that's crazy.
But then we went to hemp fest where there's like 50,000 people smoking weed,
no fights.
It was like nothing.
Everybody's like,
you bump into some of the right,
terribly sorry man.
I'm like,
wow.
I remember pointing that out being like I can't believe there isn't lake.
Cause we had a room full of 200 art capacity was only 235 and I mean there's
fights all the time.
Well imagine if you had like 50,000 people.
That Tequila fest,
that's the start of the Zombie apocalypse right there.
Yeah.
You'd be like of just a patch of people eating a joke.
It's a fucking horrible drug.
But again,
I support it.
It's just,
I just keep thinking that we're in the transitionary age,
we're in the age where people are finally getting it.
And that this though what's happened in Seattle,
in Colorado and Washington DC is the first blip of this new movement that's
going to spread across the country and,
and the,
the politicians are going to have to adapt because politicians are whores and
that is the good thing about them.
They're,
their ideology is based entirely on which way the wind's blowing,
so because of that,
it's kind of cool.
It's,
it's a business,
right?
Their prime objective is to win and get elected because not only them,
but all the people that worked with them campaigning for the last year.
They lose their jobs too.
Yeah,
right.
Get that Chris Christie fucker to see that guy.
He's still saying that marijuana is dangerous and addictive.
Meanwhile,
he's just ridiculously over obese.
They just thought,
I think it's so accurate.
He's so disgusting.
They just did.
They just did a report.
Rather they said he spent $82,000 and food at NFL Games of taxpayer's money.
Are you kidding me?
I did not see that bad.
$2,000 in food at NFL Games.
Wow.
This fucking guy who is morbidly obese just overflowing out of his shirts and
his pants.
Just clear food addiction and eating addiction like clearly a hundred percent by
the way.
You know,
I had this guy,
Dr Dan Engle.
Leon on the other day was talking about the,
he works with people with addictions and trying to treat these addictions like
food addictions and sugar addictions in particular,
or one of the most difficult ones to treat because you've got to eat.
Everybody eats.
It's not like heroin,
like you'd kick heroin and no one's like,
dude,
you've got to do a little hair stay alive.
Like you don't have to do a little heroin.
Jamie and I were talking to before you arrived and food,
uh,
sugar processed sugar was artificially put into the majority of our foods,
like back in the 70s and eighties so that you have a taste for it.
That's why we're so addicted to like,
like it's in things you don't even think about.
Spaghetti sauce,
sandwich meats,
things like that.
So you look,
you're like the sugar in this.
Like it's an everything.
I try to,
I go through the rings around my cabin to go two weeks without sugar.
I've never succeeded.
I the,
I went a whole month without beating off ones.
Shut up.
I'm documented it on my blog,
my website.
I would fail that addiction test.
Why did it because I had to do it,
you know,
I didn't have to do it,
but I had to do it because I said I was going to do it.
Yeah.
You know,
and I wrote about it,
but it was just ridiculous.
You find yourself becoming more aggressive more?
No,
I'm just horny all the time.
Like people give me a hug and I get a hard fuck when you,
you say you're not going to tell,
you don't realize like how much jerking off is like maintenance.
Like it keeps you clear.
Like you don't have the,
this overwhelming need,
this pulsating overwhelming need,
you know,
and you,
uh,
if you,
if you go 30 days without beating off,
you'll kind of understand that.
And most people don't do that unless they have like a really low sex drive.
Never gone that long.
But sugar,
um,
I've never tried.
I sh I have very much limit my sugar,
my sugar try that too.
But I've tried a few weeks just to really cut it,
like really look at everything and,
and other than even then it,
I'd never succeeded.
But like fruit and stuff like at least natural sugar.
I wasn't as much,
but just process.
I'm like,
I'm going to try to get rid of nothing process.
But then I have kids and stuff and the cupboards full of Shit and then I'm like,
ah,
fuck it.
I'll grab one of these the other day my wife brought home Krispy Kreme donuts.
Those are crap.
Those already been,
what have you done?
There's no way of those kids.
Those came in the house.
I crushed the whole thing.
They're brutal.
The good.
Um,
you've got to get the cream filled ones because the,
the regular ones,
they're only good like right when they come out of the oven.
But the regular ones,
the cream filled ones are good for days.
I haven't had those ones lays cream filled.
So we don't have Krispy Kremes.
Not In Canada too much.
We have Tim Horton's.
Tim Horton's can't carry Krispy Kremes jock strap.
Okay.
That's a fellow I've eaten 10 horny Tim Horton's donuts there.
Dog Shit.
There are eye.
They're okay.
They're good.
No,
they're way better than Dunkin donuts.
That's not true at all.
It's just fucking disgusting.
Boston cream donuts,
those,
those fucking,
you ever have one of those off sessions?
Canadians are so into being Canadian
as love being Canadian.
We are proud.
It's a great country.
Don't get me wrong.
My favorite country other than America without a doubt as Canada and they,
they're the nicest people and it's one of the reasons why it's so difficult to
get up there.
That's why people always say,
when are you gonna Bring Joey [inaudible]?
Joey Diaz has armed kidnapping on his,
on his resume.
It's very fucking tough to get into Canada with arm kit.
You can't even get into Canada if you had a bar fight,
you know.
Well now both countries,
same in the US.
If you have a DUI you can't come to the United States from Canada and you can't
come from the US to Canada.
Do you have a Dui?
You are restricted from travel.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a good one.
You know if we could keep more people from driving trunk it would be a way
better place.
But Canada is particularly stringent on the amount of people and the type of
people that lets in.
And it's one of the reasons why I've always said it's such a nice country.
It's like you guys like you value good behavior up there,
you value nice people.
Well another thing that's a big advantage for us,
like when people make comparisons because the culture is very similar in some
ways and very different in a lot of ways.
I find the United States is very polarized and they're like,
it's much more like,
are you a Republican or Democrat?
Are you left or right?
Or you're religious or not.
Not to say that doesn't exist in Canada.
I don't find it as intense as it is in the United States,
but we have such a small population.
Right?
Right.
Like there was more people in the state of California then our entire country,
which is really weird.
So we don't have to deal like when you get more and more people,
you know,
things get more and more complicated.
There's different social structures and history and religious and bands.
You guys are dealing with Shitty donuts.
So there's that too.
You're always having to,
Tim,
why don't these are awesome,
awesome,
awesome.
Barely edible.
This much,
much better.
I highly disagree on that.
And they're good.
Mad there.
I'll give Krispy Kremes are awesome,
but Timmies are a close second.
Not even no for up there.
You have no choices.
What else you got?
I tried Dunkin donuts when I lived in New York.
Put dairies disgusting.
No idea what you're talking about when you're making me make me sick.
Isn't it weird like we would give a fuck if you enjoy something.
I don't.
It's like that's fighting words.
You did somebody,
Timmy,
you use a windows dude,
you should get a Mac.
Oh I don't even get in.
I just have an old beat up laptop that's still survived and it's a Mac.
I've had it for like eight years.
Still works fine.
People get mad at you.
Well at least now with the new film we're in production for you.
Like cause you backup all your footage.
So we bought one through the production.
So I get that one.
When it's done,
I'll take what?
Operating system using feral hacks house cat.
I have a really old one.
It still has,
it still has one of those DVD drives and so where you can actually put one of
those among my other laptop.
This one doesn't have it.
It has like I have a USB one which I've never used.
I bought it like when I'm like,
I'm definitely gonna need this.
I've never used it.
Once I do,
DVDs are done.
They're done.
It's just like those goddamn floppy disks.
When they,
when they got rid of the floppy disks,
everybody's like,
Steve Jobs.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Are you crazy?
No floppy disk,
and then he was right.
They are interesting in the movie industry,
those they haven't been able to recover.
What DVDs used to make like Dow digital downloads not there.
It hasn't been.
It's called piracy son.
Yeah,
it up.
If anyone knows that.
I know like the union had been seen millions of times and we still hadn't got
into the green with that one.
Wow.
Millions of times where it gets crazy.
There's just 10 sec.
If we just got 10 cents a download,
we would be doing really good.
You'd be rich as fuck rich as fuck.
It's like five,
5 million.
If you look at all the different places where it's been illegally download,
we've,
we stopped calculate where you just add up on youtube and on it's like five,
6 million.
That's a real issue when it comes to making a documentary isn't it?
Getting the funding really tough cause docs are,
in Canada at least we're fortunate because we have like the tax credit system
and there's a lot of grant programs so that Canadian artists can still survive.
The problem with that is you have Canadian content laws.
Yeah.
So you got some dog shit that sneak through sneaks through.
I wouldn't say a sneaker,
I'd say majority it is,
but docs,
the good thing is is all it has to be to qualify as can con is as long as the
crew is Canadian producing it.
Right?
So like the culture high is a Canadian content film,
but that's doesn't feel very Canadian.
Right?
It's much more about us politics and it's all featuring us and international
interviews.
Right.
Docs is the one that really works well for it.
You guys have that Mark Emery guy up there too,
which is a strange case.
This guy,
cause it's very polarizing on both sides in both ways.
Like that guy was selling seeds which were totally legal in your country and the
local law enforcement was not willing to prosecute him.
So the DEA came in to extradite him and we talked about that in,
in the union where it was just like,
look,
it's the same as if we bought a machine gun from the United States,
not legal in Canada.
Right.
But we don't extradite the guy that bought it to the United State or like you
know,
we don't go to the United States and say,
Hey your guy sold a gun to Canada.
He has to come up and serve time in Canada.
We arrest the guy that bought it.
So with the seeds,
the same thing with mark.
Right.
And he was giving,
he was paying taxes to the government.
They had no issue on the seeds that he got arrested for.
And then he was giving to,
you know,
drug rehabilitation clinics and a whole bunch of things.
And almost like in that case the government's kind of in on it because they take
money.
Like you guys took the tax money and then you still sent him to the United
States.
The flask assign the official release to allow him.
Right.
Why would they do that?
That's where it was funny cause a lot of people,
I mean he,
you know,
mark Emery is really aggressive and he wanted to be a martyr and he,
that's the polarizing aspect and it gets tough because a lot of people,
you know,
didn't like the way he did things but the,
some people that were not in the argument where too much,
we're just against giving up a Canadian citizen to go serve time over there.
They were like,
you should be.
That was the one that everyone was kind of on the side being like that shouldn't
be done.
You know,
we should not send him over there for laws that,
you know,
he didn't order the seed.
Somebody else ordered it to the United States.
He shouldn't be sent down there to go serve his time.
He just got out of prison like a year ago.
Yeah,
and he's,
you know,
he's back to his old ways and smoking pot and making videos and all this stuff.
I mean,
they didn't put a dent in it.
They actually did make him a martyr.
You know,
he was in the transcripts we showed in the union did,
they said this is a dent to the legalization movement and everything.
It was much more of a political arrest for the DEA than it was anything else.
And actually the prosecutor that help send him to the has actually come out
recently and said we should change marijuana laws and not put people,
he still thinks that sending mark Emery way was the right thing to do as a
prosecutor.
But he thinks that the law should now be changed because they're draconian and
they really aren't.
I mean it's,
there's argument about
it.
There's no,
no one can make except dancy gray is,
did you see her argument with two Chainz?
Yes.
I see all her stuff.
I post them and tweet them.
They always get a good reaction with her.
She's adorable.
She's almost like a plant.
She's almost like a plant by the marijuana industry to try it.
I like the marijuana community to try to like make the ultimate dumb villain
that epitomizes the anti legalization movement.
Marijuana makes you fat and lazy,
but then she'll say the exact opposite of that.
Right.
You SOC
ray bests.
Exactly.
Well,
yeah.
I,
I have to believe with her that she doesn't even believe all of her by,
I have to think it's like when you had Dr. Carl Hart on the show and he talked
about going on,
um,
dark bill O'Reilly O'Reilly.
Yeah.
Right.
And he was saying how he was great right before we started rolling camera.
Then when we rolled camera,
he was totally different.
Right.
And he was trying to get at me and he was living the character.
I'd have to think that Naz Nancy grace is the same.
No,
I think you're probably right.
I think there's a lot of those folks that are in that public eye,
um,
that are involved in the business of getting eyes on them and they know the
controversy is what sells this.
That's how you got to do it.
You know they are Nancy grace,
the effects of Nancy grace.
I want to hear this.
Nancy.
Nancy grace.
Look at her.
Oh wows in evidence that Trayvon Martin did have marijuana in his system at the
time he died.
What difference,
if any,
does that make?
Because I've seen too many felonies.
She's on hot sales are growing part like this guy up in Connecticut.
To me it means that he is less likely to pick a fight with someone.
I mean,
people on pot shoot each other.
Isn't it true that when you smoke pot,
you just want to lay on the sofa and eight people on pot kill families wipe out
a whole family.
The
connotation,
lethargy with the munchies with wanting to eat.
We're being laid back,
not with chasing somebody down,
jumping out from behind bushes,
beating when the head till till they're pulpy and,
and,
and basically starting mortal Kombat.
That's not what you typically equate with.
Smoking a Doobie.
That's hilarious.
Or I've gotta be smoking or I've got to be high on pot.
Can you clearly say Nancy won the debate.
They're debating herself.
I feel like Nancy had all the good points.
Yeah.
Well,
she's a business person.
You know,
that's her business is Nancy grace.
The business of Bill O'reilly is bill O'Reilly's got to get in your face and
call you a moron and shut you up because bill O'Reilly is to that seven year old
man with a hearing aid.
That's his,
uh,
his audience,
that scared man,
that's afraid that Mexicans are gonna move into his neighborhood and his hands
are shaking when he goes,
where's my remote remote?
Where's the remote?
And the wife is just a prisoner of this guy's fucking,
you know,
no one's allowed to touch the remote for this TV.
That's the bill O'Reilly Fan.
He just said,
Myers,
Bill O'Reilly.
Well,
that was,
you know,
that was part of that Brett really wanted to tackle in indirect,
in the culture.
I was that part of the media.
Right.
And how it's become such a business and Jank breaks that down really great in
the film of like breaking down in the history of media and how the airwaves were
originally given to get news.
We'll give you the airways,
you give us news,
but then anytime they tackle the subject that kind of conflicted with the
political views of Washington and they're like,
okay,
wait a minute,
we don't want you talking about that news.
Right?
We don't want you talking about that.
And then they realize they can make money off it and started getting sponsors
and then it was like,
okay,
well we can't touch subjects like this.
And when you had Jank on your show,
we touch on that whole MSNBC thing that he had right where he goes in and he
started pushing buttons of both sides and saying other both corrupt and then
systematically corrupt.
Right?
Because you're funded by people to argue points based on campaign money that you
got is a great point that Brett fought hard to have in the film,
that the audience seemed to really take two when it released.
So it illuminates the issue.
The issue is,
it's not as clear as like,
some people think this is bad for you and some people think this is good for
you.
And you know,
here's the debatable evidence.
It's not,
there's no debatable evidence.
You look at the evidence,
you go,
okay,
well there's no one has ever died from it ever.
No one has ever got cancer from it ever.
No one.
I mean all this idea like the,
I love when they start going like,
uh,
what's his name?
Gabor Montay.
How do you say his name?
Gabber medtech.
Yeah.
I've only seen it written.
I haven't heard it.
Trust me.
We were at the same thing.
I would tell him we met him.
Yeah.
Um,
one of the things that he talked about was the instances of psychosis and which
is fascinating because you know,
they're both,
it's caused sock psychotic episodes and some people,
no,
it actually doesn't.
They're the uniform number of psychotic episodes and people is pretty much it.
It's in line with the population and if you have a hundred people,
one of those people is going to have issues and,
and when,
if you have a hundred people that smoke pot and one of those peoples has issues,
you can't correlate that with pot.
You just can't because breakdown name,
we break down the schizophrenia clip.
We have like a two minute clip.
I don't know,
but like did we have to Jamie?
It's on youtube.
If you just go the culture I schizophrenia and it's got all of them breaking in
my head because you guys did a great job with that documentary and I want more
people to see it.
It's just more the more these things get out there,
the more people see this.
More people see the union and there's,
there's so many of them now.
There's so many of these documentaries now it's just,
well and explain this,
let's play this.
Schizophrenia.
Schizophrenia just wants split and you will come into
wait.
The more you mess with cannabis,
the more it can mess with your mind.
Even worse than the UK first seven years as a research and were devoted to a
schizophrenia.
I can tell you that is ridiculous.
We looked at the evidence.
I think we must have gone through about 2000 papers and it doesn't cost
schizophrenia.
Maybe there are some individuals with schizophrenia in which the illness is
brought on perhaps a little earlier because they smoke cannabis.
There are often is what's called an a precipitating event,
a precipitating event or something like an important loss of a person,
a severe car accident.
It certainly can be exacerbated by a number of drugs you know are bad alcohol
trip that could serve as a precipitating event to the fact is schizophrenia has
a prevalence of about 1% the world around cannabis use,
but start with a sixties it's gone up like that.
So you've introduced this new thing.
If it's schizophrenia Janick we should see a significant uptick in
schizophrenia.
We should see more people with schizophrenia,
schizophrenia,
and stay just like that.
In all of the epidemiologic studies that I'm aware of,
there is no uptick.
So if marijuana causes schizophrenia,
it was introduced.
Now we should have more schizophrenia.
We don't see that.
We will shortly see sub a little rise and I'd given the numbers of people who
use this,
you really,
they need to strip this back and address this from a neutral platform to
understand it.
Anything to do with mental health is such a tenuous issue.
Build up on different contributing factors and by applying it all to cannabis,
you are possibly doing more harm because you are negating or all these other
fighters that certainly prior power.
Yeah,
that's,
that guys summed it up perfectly,
perfectly negating all those other factors.
Life is,
uh,
you know,
it's a series of factors and that is doing much more harm because you're not
looking at all the other things.
You're trying to find the gist.
It's because of this.
It's because of that,
right.
Instead of,
you know,
looking at the broader picture like,
Oh,
maybe there was mental abuse,
maybe there's neglect as a child,
and then gabber really does a great thing where he talks about addiction and how
early childhood development and how the brain grows so rapidly that it develops,
you know,
certain things that those end up becoming the crutch for you later on because
you had neglect when you were younger or when you had this,
right.
It stems so much from early childhood.
In fact,
he did a study because he was a Holocaust survivor,
right?
His family,
they escaped.
And when he was perfectly healthy baby,
then all of a sudden he became really colicky.
So his mother called their physician was like,
oh my God,
I know he's not slow.
He's screaming all night.
And the doctor said,
well,
Mrs Mat,
Hey,
if you don't mind me asking your Jewish correct?
And she said,
yeah,
what does that have to do with anything?
He said,
we have an epidemic of Jewish babies,
uh,
that our call lucky now ever since the war has been announced.
And explain what college he is for.
People don't have kids call it.
He is like kids that just nonstop cry.
They're always like,
as a cold call,
lucky.
I don't know.
We'd have to look that up.
Jam Not done,
but they like,
I've never experienced it with my children,
fortunately,
but I've had parents that literally said they see how they could go to purse
martem depression.
They just,
the kids do not sleep.
They're always uncomfortable.
Screaming like crazy all night,
like eight,
12 hours a day to where you think they're going to scream themselves to where
their heart might stop.
Right.
It's panicky.
You get,
so the physician hasn't announced that and Gabber looked at the study and be
like,
well,
what would infants or children know about the war and Hitler?
Why would that make them call lucky?
Well,
what are children?
What's the only thing they're growing on him to absorbing at that young age?
Their parents who are now stressed,
they're in fear,
they're scared of what's going to happen in the war.
They're scared about going to prison camps and that fear,
intention and arguments and everything else is already affecting the young child
to the point where they start to become like they can feel that,
right?
Like,
and he goes on that the,
I don't want to just keep running clips,
but there's another great clip if people want to go look,
the business insider picked it up,
the addiction side of the Gab or breaks down.
So con like he does it like to put in one sentence,
he says it this way.
He says,
you know,
although the addiction itself is a problem and we should be concerned about it,
it's not the problem.
It's the addicts attempt to solve a problem in the first place.
Yeah.
That is a really good bit.
Uh,
that really good clip rather.
And the the the talk about genes and then how it affects the way genes express
themselves.
Like that's really crazy.
Like I didn't even know that.
We didn't know that.
Like I remember Alma actually can make you addicted to things and,
and uh,
the childhood it,
there's a study that he references that showed that children that had had,
you know,
lost in the family divorce abuse,
we're 600 times greater to become,
go to business.
If you go business insider,
the culture high,
it has the,
the addiction clip.
Yeah.
I just think that all of this information like this what we just played about
schizophrenia and this about addiction and genetics and the ever the evidence
now it's just so overwhelming that when you have a Nancy grace or you have,
you know,
like the old Ronald Reagan clip,
it becomes almost comedy.
It's like it's so proposed.
But the thing is like,
and you had a Dr. Carl Hart talked about when he was on your podcast though,
is they don't want to come off like it sucks going on their show because that's
their realm where they can get you on points and they can get,
because sometimes you can get a certain doctor like Gabber Matay if you can let
them talk and really explain it,
he'll sue are you?
But if you were to debate and get points that when and over shout,
he might not come off what those shows are a joke man.
Any of those shows where they have like Anderson Cooper standing there and he's
talking to five different people that are in five
different locations and they're all yelling in your bases.
Then the arguably the worst way to communicate ever.
Like get anyone of those fucks on a podcast and sit down with them for three
hours and then you'd find out what they're really like.
Like Nancy Grace.
You Imagine Nancy grace on a podcast talking about marijuana for three hours to
do.
You know,
if she couldn't leave,
she couldn't go.
This conversation is nonsense.
Mr. Rowe in your wasting my time.
Can we set up a pay per view event to that and make that have run away?
She would not.
They would not come.
There's no way she would because if she did,
I mean you wouldn't have to yell at her.
You wouldn't have to get angry.
You would just break it down over and over again.
Do you know how ridiculous is it?
Like show her the facts.
Show her her own debate against herself.
All these people that are doing this fat.
Fuck Christie,
get that dummy.
You know I'm,
I'm a fat shamer.
I'll tell you right now a fat shame the fuck out of that fat.
Fuck.
I don't believe in fat shaming.
I think it's nonsense.
It's Goddamn nonsense.
I'm not into it.
Um,
and that guy is a dangerous person.
Those,
those words that come out of his mouth in a position of power will affect
people.
There's young children that hear what he says.
They listened to the news and they will start to believe that stupid shit little
and people that are way more scared to admit maybe they made a mistake and
correct it and we'll continue a lie and push that ideology on people for that.
That is,
I mean you had Steven Pressfield on here,
but the,
the war of art,
right?
Talked about that.
Like how resistance can push you.
Like rather than overcoming that resistance,
admitting that there was a mistake,
like,
hey,
I was wrong.
Right.
I made a mistake,
which is nice to see doctor Sanjay Gupta come out and at least like,
you know,
say like,
I was fundamentally wrong about the research I presented.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's got a lot of courage for doing that.
But uh,
yeah,
the denial of the truth is bad.
Not just for the people that you're delivering the truth too,
but also to yourself.
Cause you know,
in your heart of hearts that you're a bullshitter.
If you are somehow or another pushing some nonsense,
false narrative,
just because it reinforces what you've already said and you find that over and
over again with humans.
They just don't want to ever admit that they were incorrect or they got
bamboozled.
Scary.
I mean that's what keep me.
Did you see um,
the um,
going clear documentary?
Yes.
I did.
Just watched it the other day.
God Damn Fascinating.
But it sort of touches on that a bit because you see these people that we didn't
want to admit that this religion called crazy they'd gotten into was a bullshit.
The something someone created a really retarded science fiction author.
Created a gigantic religions.
Yes.
Actually give him props that he was able to just say religions are the most
profitable thing cause you don't have to pay tax.
And I'm the science fiction writer and once to get whatever,
what's the level like?
Oh v three.
Then you get the notes from him and when the religion is,
and I love where they have Paul Haggis on at that point.
And he's like,
what the fuck is this?
He's like,
he's like,
I was into the all helping people and trying to make the world a better place
and do all that.
He's like,
but once I read this,
he was like,
I'm not into this whole thing.
The xy on ruler,
whenever z news,
he knew.
That's what we also kind of realize that the l Ron Hubbard himself was very much
like very likely like having mental health issues and he was trying to self
diagnose.
Yup.
And that's why one of the things I actually like about Scientology and uh,
you know,
I don't want to bash,
I don't know enough about it to bash it other than the really scary retarded
shit.
Yeah.
But I've,
I've known some people that have been in it and they've been like really goal
oriented people and they really like have been focused and they like try to get
their shit together.
And one of the guys that left,
he said that he left Scientology as a religion,
but he still believed in it as a,
as a,
as a practice,
as a practice for like mental,
like awareness or for managing the mind.
You know,
cause I think the lot of their principals,
a lot of the ideas came from psychology and they came from,
I mean he had some,
some like almost like self remedy sort of ideas of how to like manage his
craziness and manage his mind.
And I don't think it's all bad.
No it but isn't that isn't that ultimately would like for to for to me I thought
like all ideology,
like some of the ideas of like treating others as you'd want to be treated
yourself.
Like isn't that what they all stem from?
But then like Scientology and the film at least and other ones,
then you get people in positions of power in those places.
Right.
And then it starts being done to know it's the way I depict these readings.
And if you disobey then you burn in Hell or whatever your that's always like I
read a lot of them.
Like I grew up around um,
uh,
east Indians and seek and a lot of their stuff I liked were like the original
seat temples had all four entrances saying all people are welcome,
right?
And then all rivers essentially flow to the ocean.
Meaning there's no one right way to find enlightenment or be a better person.
And,
but then,
you know,
I'm a big fan of the Sikh religion.
Yeah.
I've met a lot of those guys.
They're very cool.
I wish they would cut their hair
so much.
So much of what they're doing is like,
I liked the way they behave.
I like the,
they're not,
they don't proselytize and not rude about it,
you know?
And when they dress up for their weddings,
their shit looks way better than a Tux.
Yeah.
I think they have some crazy marijuana drink to that someone taught,
I think it's called,
I think it's called Bang Bha and June or something like that.
But it's like marijuana mixed with yogurt.
There's like a certain sex of,
yeah.
See if he could find that.
Jeremy,
there's certain sex of,
uh,
of the Sikhs who,
they,
they drink this marijuana yogurt combinations like Hash and yogurt.
I just think it's sweet.
And when they go to the wedding,
they have the fucking sword and it go pawn their thing.
Like we get,
we get a toxin,
a tie.
They just had like emperors with weapons.
I was like,
well you call it by,
it's like I'd much rather dress like that.
Yeah,
no,
they,
I mean I'm like,
here it is B h a n g
a beverage prepared from the leaves and flowers of the female cannabis plant has
a long history of use in the Indian sub continent with the buds of the plant
maturing the spring,
the preparation of Ba,
I think it's called Bong.
Bong has traditionally been associated with the harvest festivals of old La
[inaudible] or Holly in March.
And the vice,
uh,
how you say that vice suck he vice hockey ice hockey in April.
Uh,
although drugs and alcohol per bid in Chic Ism,
not n I.
A H a n g s knee hugs,
I dunno,
are traditionally very fond of Bong,
which they call suck.
Need Don meaning giver of peace.
That's right.
Or a Sukkah prosad or IEP giver.
Yeah.
I agree with all those things.
Seeks got it right.
Yep.
I take the Bong,
be happy,
be happy.
Let's play that a thing about jeans man cause he is a business insight because
this is a pretty pretty powerful stuff.
Addiction,
the most frequently cited perceived harm associated with marijuana.
Sexy voice.
It's addiction.
Not Bad enough that it's addictive.
Highly addictive.
Right,
because I believe it is addictive and it leads to more serious drugs,
but in order to understand addiction in relation to marijuana,
one must first have an understanding of the psychology behind addiction in the
first place.
It's interesting to see or to ask who becomes addicted.
People can have sex with them and they get to it.
They can go shopping,
but some people become severely addicted to all these pursuits.
Is a pack of cards addictive?
Well no or yes,
depending on the individual,
so it's the same process no matter what the addiction is.
The only difference is really is that the substance that act is getting the
dopamine from an outside substance.
It was the bigger addict is heading.
It triggered from the particular behavior.
If I speak to a group of people or a thousand people and ask her,
how many of you have addiction issues and to any substance and number of people
put their hand up in the see,
what did it do for you?
Not what was bad about it.
You already know that,
but what did it do for you?
What was positive in your experience with it?
Well,
if you give me a sense of peace,
it gave me a pain relief.
He didn't need to feel more connected.
It made me more confident.
I could speak now and interacts with other people.
In other words,
the addict is just after wanting to be a normal human being,
and the real question is what keeps them from having those qualities in their
lives and what happened to them and so that the addiction should be seen not as
the problem,
although it is a problem,
but it's not the problem.
It's the addicts attempted to solve a problem in the first place.
The ad just shot your experiences.
Studies done in California looked at conditions such as physical,
sexual,
emotional abuse in the child's life.
The loss of a parent through death or a rankers divorce or a pan being jailed or
mental illness in the parent or addiction of Panco violence in the family.
And for each of these adverse childhood experiences,
the risk of addiction goes up exponentially by that than a male child has had
six of these adverse experiences.
His risk of having become a substance dependent injection using addict is 4600%
greater than that of a maybe 600 experiences.
It's because that trauma shapes the brain in such ways as to make the addictive
substance is more appealing to the individual.
That trauma also gives that person the pain that they will try to Dennis Kate
from or to soothe to the addictive behaviors.
It's the social and emotional environment that shapes the actual biology of the
brain.
So if you want to send somebody to addiction,
you need to look at what queen pain in their lives with a person who
occasionally has a beer occasionally,
uh,
smokes marijuana,
but genuinely they have no negative consequences.
It does not impair their head off.
It does not endanger their lives.
It does not impair their personal relationships.
You can't call those people addicts and you can't call those behaviors addictive
critical distinction between the use of substances and the addiction to
substances,
which then brings us to the war on drugs.
Basically the war on drugs is being waged against people that were abused and
traumatized and children and having mental health problems.
There's enough punishment in there in the negative consequences of the addiction
that we don't have to add punishment down to that.
How great it would be nailed to a number of deaths around the world from
cigarette consumption is five and a half million according to latest testaments
annually.
Cigarettes kill as many people as we killed and the Germans anti Jewish
genocidal
campaign,
so we have a Holocaust and anyway,
oiling to cigarettes,
you smoke more than two packs a day.
He risk for developing lung cancer was 20 fold.
That's 2000 preset based on the largest case control study ever done.
There is no evidence that marijuana increased the risk of lung cancer.
Ooh,
you got to have some consistency.
What was this?
Was this guy a million different drugs that are sanctioned by the society that
don't have that happy ending that you take too much and you're fucked.
I've got a friend who's armed.
He had to go to rehab for buying two boxes of Krispy Kremes every day and easy
would Zelle Tim Horton's.
How's how he didn't say Tim Horton.
He's from the UK.
Be Creams illegal.
I will fight any man by the way.
He suggests that and whether your buddy,
I got to get up salt and dying.
You didn't use salt,
right?
Dude,
you fucked up with salt.
If you just throw some salt on popcorn,
it's actually quite yummy,
you know,
but what'd you do?
You stupid.
Fuck you ate a pound of salt and died.
It doesn't mean we should outlaw salts.
Our society doesn't object to people jumping out of air.
I heard we heard him Graham Hancock through your podcast.
That's how we ended up getting interviewed on his sides.
It's so good.
I love climbing mountains.
Occasionally people pull off mountains and do harm to themselves.
We're just rehashing all this stuff.
Yeah.
Graham Hancock is actually involved in some,
a fascinating debate
right now with this Guy Zoe Huw os who's the head of,
I think the head of Egyptian antiquities.
He's sort of the guy that dissemination did disseminator of information in Egypt
when it comes to like how people have access to the pyramids and all the
different structures and he's been,
um,
going at it with this guy because the guy is unable or unwilling to reconsider a
lot of his statements about the age of a lot of the,
uh,
ancient Egypt monoliths and all these different structures.
You know,
they've got some clay tech-based putting it back fucking Hook into that,
right?
He pretended he didn't know what go back.
Lee Tapi was,
and it's really funny the,
the,
the debate,
but since the similar thing like a guy who's been saying something for so long
that there had,
there were no cultures more than 5,000 years ago that were capable of
sophisticated construction methods.
And he's just said this for so long that now the evidence has come out go
Beckley Tapi is 12,000 years old.
There's no doubt about it.
It is 100% there to Graham was saying there's two other ones that the initial
tests are coming out.
There was like a one in Australia and another one in Indonesia that was found
and they said it's more and more like his original theory that he was poo pooed
on is now seeming to be more and more correct.
Oh yeah.
Between him and Randall Carlson,
I mean they've really uncovered a lot of issues that there was trying to date
the history of civilization.
And the also the history of cataclysmic disasters was,
it's very problematic because there's very little evidence and it's really
difficult.
But over the past decade,
more and more evidence from geologists like all this nuclear glass,
if they're finding,
they do core samples,
they dig down 12,000 for 12,000 years.
They get like a 12,000 and at 12,000 when they get to 12,000 years universally
across Europe and Asia,
they find this tree,
it's called,
I think it's called Triton night.
It's a nuclear glass and this nuclear glass,
it exists in um,
nuclear explosion test sites and also in meteor impacts.
And so this stuff being spread out all over the place.
They think that there was a pounding that this earth took a fucking pounding by
meteors somewhere around 12,000 years ago.
And it could possibly have been the reason why the ice age ended and also could
be the reason why a massive amount of animals went extinct almost
instantaneously.
Wooly mammoths,
saber tooth tigers,
like 60% of all land mammals.
And it could be the reason why there's these ancient structures that date before
go Beckley Tapi or before you know it,
12,000 years ago,
someone covered go back Lee [inaudible].
That's how they know the reason they have a uniform age of the dirt that is
covering go Beckley Tapi so they explained it.
This is all not fringe stuff either.
By the way.
This is all like legit archeologists.
They're absolutely certain that someone covered that 12,000 years ago.
Well,
how old was it when they covered it?
No one,
no one knows.
So you don't think at least like uh,
can't test stone biocarbon leg like living things right that you can carbon
date,
right?
That's how they tested the age of the pyramids.
They tested the material that's between the stones and you know,
the bar,
the biological material,
whether it's wood or things along those lines.
You could test that stuff and get pretty accurate readings.
He,
this is what's so awesome about your podcast when we try to put a little bit of
technology and the culture of how it's radically changing things like,
I mean anyone I put onto your podcast gets hooked.
And in fact I joke cause I've been in things where you bring on such interesting
people that got me to research things that I would have never looked into
before.
Like go back lay,
tap pay.
The way that I even knew how to pronounce it was because we'd heard Graham
Hancock on here.
We,
when he did his war on consciousness bit,
right.
And I were like,
we need to get that guy for the fucking film.
Like he has to be interviewed.
Um,
and then,
you know,
when I met with Graham Hang,
but the information and getting people to look at new ideas and great
perspectives and the platform of having people come on here for a good two,
three hours to really communicate things like that trickle effect.
I've witnessed it.
I've seen people that have like been inspired by your show that have lost 50.
They're like,
man,
you're the guy that did the union,
the culture high like Joe show.
I,
I've used on it,
I've lost 60 pounds.
Like I love your stuff.
I've changed my perspective.
Like I've witnessed how it's already having a trickle effect of putting out,
just getting new information out there,
getting people to think outside the box.
And when we talked earlier about the ego kind of preventing you from sometimes
progressing well,
you have a lot of great people.
You stress it on here all the time.
But other people,
you have great interviews that do a two.
Like I found for me,
even at times,
there's times when I'm like,
Hey,
you know what?
I should like self reflect.
I should get back into like boxing,
martial arts and you know,
maybe my ego is getting swelling.
Like it's,
it's good to get into that.
And I left going back to,
I boxed competitively when I was younger and I love going back in there now and
getting beat up by these young guys cause it's really humbling.
Right.
Bad for your brain though dude.
Super Bad for your boy.
You know,
I don't do it.
What punches to the head or aren't good?
Try Yoga.
I've been doing a lot of yoga lately.
Do that also for the ego to uh,
my daughter wants to now get into Jujitsu so we're going to be great.
Yeah,
I love Jujitsu.
Well,
what I love about Jujitsu is it doesn't have the,
the striking the head.
I mean I grew up a striker in my whole,
I mean the reason why I became who I am I think is because of the trials and
tribulations of martial arts and going through competition and,
and all the,
the fear and the overcoming that fear and all that stuff for me.
And also like the self reflection,
the fact that it,
it makes you very objective about your abilities,
your you,
you have to assess yourself in a very,
very clear way.
Otherwise you're going to leave vulnerabilities and you're going to get hurt.
I couldn't picture who I'd be without my boxing coach and putting like,
it was very good for me in my teenage years to um,
you know,
build confidence,
humility.
Because the first time you get in any sparring session,
you get lit up,
lit up.
But that's health like other than the actual physical break,
it's good to realize that you're not
the man at everything.
Right.
And when you can't be,
it takes a long time to be the men.
Do you mean,
how do you think Floyd may where they got to be 48 no,
and untouchable fucking countless hours in the gym.
I mean,
you could call that guy a wife beater and a piece of shit and a dummy and he
can't read and you probably write about all those things,
but what you,
you can't deny is the hard work that he put into that craft paid off.
And anyone that thinks that just going to figure that out right away.
You're just not from the little bit of boxing I did.
There's,
you're not figuring it out right away.
There's some physical gifts some people bring to the table,
unquestionably,
but it's one of those things that you just have to work really hard at.
And my belief is that when you work really hard at something and you get better
at something,
that thing becomes a vehicle for developing your human potential and then you
can transfer that same sort of energy and focus and the lessons that you learned
from that into all different walks of life.
The more extreme the situation is,
the more difficult the task is.
The more you learn about yourself and pursuing that task and the more beneficial
it is to you.
Outside of that task.
I couldn't agree more because you know,
a lot of complications when I first did the union and getting into the industry
and getting like,
you know,
I want it to be able to storytell and make films and documentaries as my living,
but it was the union.
I mean,
that was the first one,
first one,
which you really knocked it out of the fucking park.
Thank you.
It for your first project to be that good.
It was.
But to make the finances and deal with Ia is,
you know,
you're very familiar with the film industry and not really,
well the entertainment industry,
I'll say,
um,
you know,
took a while.
But you know,
I even put it on my business cards.
I put creative hustler because I think some of the things of overcoming
adversity and objections and the work you have to put in that I learned from
boxing and applied really well to being like constantly rejected,
being told you're idea's stupid.
Like so many people have said the union would never work like your dominant
[inaudible] who's wants to see this?
And then when it blew,
I actually have our distributor took it as a favor to somebody else saying it
will never have any commercial success.
What year did you do the 2007 that's crazy.
That was almost 10 years ago.
That's so weird.
Eight years ago today.
Yeah.
Weird.
And it's,
it's kind of amazing that that was your first film.
It's,
I look back now and I don't think I,
you know,
we couldn't have done any better.
It was,
you know,
like you said,
a grand slam for our first film.
And then since then I've been very fortunate to work on lots of other great
docs.
Like we worked on I and Bruce Lee,
then I did the good son with ray ray,
boom,
boom man sceney and you've watched the good son.
But I've heard amazing things.
A ball man that you want to talk about.
A guy that overcome adversity.
Like you're a boxing fancy,
you know,
ray story there,
right?
As a kid,
his dad was a number one contender,
right?
But then was drafted to the war and wasn't able to fight,
took shrapnel,
came back into the ring,
was never the same fighter,
got beat up,
damaged design.
So at 10 years old,
10 ray makes a promise to his dad,
Dad,
I will win the world
title that you sold deserve to fight for.
And His dad's agreement don't go through.
It's so hard.
21 ray wins the world title and gives it to his dad and says it's finally where
it should be after 42 years.
And then raise whole reason for getting into boxing was for righteous reasons to
win a world title for his father.
And then in his third title defense,
he takes the life of a father in Duke,
who Kim,
when he kills Kim in the 14th round and Kim and only found out two or three
months before he was leaving to fight raid that his wife was pregnant.
He never even got to meet his son.
So in the good son,
ray meets the son of the man that he killed 30 years later,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Being a part of that,
Jen Reyes and then three months,
how does he handle it?
Ray Ray had come to peace with it a long time ago.
Right?
But he really wanted to do this for Jeewan,
right?
Cause g one wanted to meet him and wanted to put at rest and let him know that,
you know,
it was just two warriors that went to war like,
but for the ending of that fight,
you know the fight itself is a great fight.
Like Duke who actually wrote in his notes,
we found all this stuff cause we went to Korea and interviewed his trainer and I
know the whole story and he actually wrote like,
I will die in the ring tonight before I like that was his,
he came from nothing.
And Korea,
like Barnum nor like right next to the North Korean border,
slept in a pen with a horse like poor,
poor.
He fought to eat.
So fighting ray was his chance at success.
He was not going to lose that fight.
And the first four rounds,
I mean he takes it to Ray,
right?
They go hard.
They go.
So you know,
now going on this journey with these docs,
like I now I'm hooked.
I don't want to do anything other than dogs because you meet Ray.
Ray is such an amazing individual.
Like,
I mean his brother was murdered three months before he won his world title.
That still did not detour him.
Right.
He stuck right in their,
won his first world title.
When you,
when you watched the WT,
like if you were to script what happened to him with like him promising since he
was 10 years old to win a world title,
his brother getting murdered three months before he wins.
Then tragically taking the lightly,
you'd be like,
this is ridiculous script.
This is two fantastic like to bullshit.
But it really happened to him.
Sometimes people's lives do play out like a ridiculous movie.
Nothing but amazing.
Great things to say about [inaudible] amazing individual.
Are you a fan of documentaries and he's like a Werner Herzog fan or anything?
I don't like any particular one person.
Just I do love docs.
So like I,
for me when I was hooked,
and I think I might've said this last time was on a podcast,
but when you're in that audience and your documentary has an emotional
connection with the audience and you see them like when raise film,
but people are crying.
Like guys,
I know there were full a motorcycle guys that I was friends with.
Like they're crying and they're in front of them.
They're like,
dude,
you made me cry.
And for all the boys,
and you know when Jason,
David and his son Jayden are on there with the things that people are quite like
and you see it has that impact and then you see it being,
you know,
universities and stuff.
People reaching out to me saying,
I used your film as a catalyst for my graduating argument and
it's tough to just want to go make an action film where everybody shooting each
other later.
Right?
Or it's tough when you see something that is not only a great story but has
emotional impact,
right?
Well,
when done correctly,
the medium of documentaries can have an amazing impact.
You can really get that.
One of the fast,
I think it is the best as long as like it's done correctly.
Like the information is like,
it's not Michael Morde.
Yeah,
I know what I mean.
Yes.
Unfortunately he,
he can do so good,
but then he pushes it too far for me.
I'm like,
leave the facts,
don't make someone look stupid.
It doesn't really help.
Not necessarily bad to make certain people look stupid if they are stupid,
which you can't do is edit the little snippets to fill your narrative.
And you know,
that's what he's guilty of.
You know,
like he's done.
He's,
he's done more harm than good.
And he got lumped into that group of guys that people will automatically like
knee jerk called deceptive.
I think he did some great work and the bowling for Columbine was fascinating and
Roger,
Roger and me I think has got the best one.
Yeah.
And that was his first one and I think that was the purest one.
And uh,
and he really built the industry,
set the bar.
He's like the Michael Jordan for it.
Like he,
he made feature docs mainstream.
Yeah.
And like the bowling for Columbine,
did he even get into mental health issues and prescription drugs and I don't
think mostly about guns.
Mostly about guns.
It's not a gun issue.
That's a mental health issue.
I wrote this on Twitter but I'll stand by it to this country has a mental health
issue disguise as a gun problem and that's,
that's really what it is.
Well look at when we just had with Gab or explains right,
like it's early childhood and then yeah,
if someone gets a dangerous weapon in their hands when they have mental
problems,
bad things can happen and it's so hard to fix people of that.
It's so hard once,
once your mind has gone down this awful path of addiction and childhood trauma
and all these horrible life experiences and you have compensated or under
compensated or over compensated and you're affected by that.
And like the idea of becoming a balanced human being,
it seems like unattainable.
It seems it's,
it's incredibly difficult for the fears.
The crazy part,
you don't know.
I'd,
one of my best friends going through went manic bipolar,
right?
Like he had a big event that caused it and he was wrongly prescribed some
antidepressants and one summer he just started acting really sporadically out of
character.
Right.
But this was before,
this was in 2003 the same year that my,
my father passed away.
So it wasn't like you,
none of us put our finger on it right away.
Like,
oh you have a menu.
Like people are just like,
you're being an asshole.
Like why did it change?
Why?
Why are you so spread?
Like cause it wasn't common knowledge like you don't,
and people that have it happening at the time,
they don't wake up in the morning and be like,
hmm,
I think I'm imbalanced and I have a mental health issue.
Right.
You have to go cease.
And then someone's like,
Hey I can,
like once he sat down with someone,
it was two seconds,
they're like,
you were bipolar,
right?
Like then they started doing the blood tests and they started testing to what
would work and
now he's super successful.
He's balanced and he's taking his lithium and certain drugs can literally stop
that.
They can nip that in the bud if you get it right,
if you get it right,
but you have to be very careful.
One thing he was very good at is he didn't want to stay on antidepressants,
right?
So the lithium balances him,
but then they originally they wanted to get him so he like his arm looked like a
heroin addict for a while.
He was getting all these different tests and see what what because uh,
like care Santa Maria broke this down too.
There's very different like inhibitors and neuro Hibita is when it comes to
antidepressants,
right?
He wanted to wean off of that.
So what a lot of them encourage,
which comes back to kind of where we're saying like diet,
exercise.
A lot of these things weigh into mental health,
right?
You can't just throw it on the drug,
Like,
Oh,
you're an addict.
Like so he's very big on,
he runs marathons,
he exercised like,
and that really helps,
you know,
the natural endorphins and stuff that he needs.
So he doesn't have to be on antidepressants ready.
Works out crazy.
He doesn't drink alcohol because that's a depressant.
And that can cause thing.
So even if it's a business meeting or something,
he'll try to be very,
maybe you know,
he'll have a social beer or something,
but he tries not to drink too much because he says he's told me that he's like,
if he does for a few business,
he's like,
I can feel it the next day.
I can feel I'm a little off.
I'm a little cloudy.
Right.
Like my cognitive functions a little slower.
So he's like,
I tried just to stay away from for me,
cause I know that can be problematic when he got,
it sounds like he got very lucky that the very loud with medication that can
treat him.
I know a dude who was always a little off and then over the last four or five
years has become just a complete paranoid.
I mean I want to say paranoid schizophrenia,
I don't know.
But I mean he literally believes that everything is a conspiracy.
Everything in the world is tied to mind control tests and you know,
it's,
it's sad to see,
you know,
I'm,
it's just one of those things like,
you know,
you,
you run into people like that and you just go,
man,
that could be me.
Like I could be trapped in that hell too.
And I'm super proud of my,
because like you said,
he's one of the only guys I know that is really like,
he's awesome now.
He's really made his life successful.
Like a Lotta when he was diagnosed,
he started sending us like stuff to understand bipolar where it's like 85% of
them die.
It's not a good,
but like either,
um,
you know,
abuse of substances,
car accidents because things become a video game,
right?
Like he talks about it now,
joking about like,
he's like,
man,
when I was in my crazy days,
like I used to ride my,
my dad's motorcycle going 80 kilometers an hour,
having a cigarette,
like on the highway,
right?
Like he's like,
I was crazy.
Like,
it's like I didn't smoke before,
but all of a sudden now I'm smoking and like,
like he was just like,
I was out of my mind spending money sporadically.
And,
but the crazy part that I was really trying to hone in as he,
you don't wake up and know,
right.
You don't.
No one tells you.
Right.
Like luckily enough,
he had a great strong family and people that were like,
let's talk to someone,
right?
Cause you're not the same.
Like within three month period you're fighting with everyone,
your friends and your emotions are like you're crying one minute.
Then you're mad.
And,
and
luckily like,
you know,
not a lot of them have a high percentage,
but he's doing extremely well.
Who mental health issues have such a stigma in this country.
People don't want to admit they have mental health issues there.
They're connected.
The PR perception by a lot of people's connected to weakness.
Let you know,
depression is a big one.
Couldn't get a job for the longest time because he'd be honest about it.
Then people didn't want to hire him.
And I was like,
dude,
that should almost be like,
like once he's like,
listen,
I'm balanced,
I'm treated like they were like,
no,
we can't take that risk.
Like he was looking at like a layman.
Can you blame them?
I mean you don't know whether or not their balance,
you don't know whether or not it's going to keep working.
Like whatever medication they're on.
And I kind of get it on both sides.
I certainly think that for a person searching for a job that has mental health
issues,
it's a huge bummer that people can't respect the fact that you've taken all the
steps and gotten your treatment and now you're a healthy person.
But if you're some guy who was running some office somewhere and you want to
keep the peace,
you want a friendly work environment,
everyone to be family and get along together and you've got this dude who's on
15 different kinds of fucking pills to keep himself from running head on in the
walls.
You know,
I could,
I can,
I can understand it,
but I think that the mental health,
the stigma,
especially to stigma on depression,
I mean half a carat Santa Maria who's in the culture high,
it was a good friend of mine.
She heard her on here as well.
That's where your podcasting inspired a lot of it.
That's awesome.
Well,
my podcast is inspired.
Me Too.
It's a call it my podcast,
but it would,
it really is,
is like,
it's a door that I found,
you know,
and I conduit.
It is,
it's a,
it's some sort of a strange antenna and a,
or a path or a channel in the river or whatever it is.
And I opened it up and I'm like,
oh,
look at this.
And then all the people are coming through,
but it's not like people say,
Oh,
you're doing a great service.
We'll have do it.
Kind of doing a great service to me too.
Like that's the number one benefactor is me.
Because I get these conversations with all these fantastic people like Graham
Hancock or Neil degrasse Tyson or you know,
Brian Cox and these like these brilliant,
brilliant people and you have these fascinating conversations.
And I get so much out of that.
I mean I'm just constantly curious and constantly filled with all these new
ideas.
And it's amazing for me.
It's amazing.
So the same for me.
Like I listened religiously.
Like I don't listen when my kids were in the car because you can go off on
tangents at time.
Whereas I'll try it and they're like,
okay,
wait,
too many f bombs.
Why was my car the other day?
And I turned it on and uh,
it was a,
the serious replay.
Cause you know,
we're on Sirius satellite,
uh,
and uh,
it was my voice and the kids sat down.
I'm like,
get the fuck at it.
You fucking Moron Daddy.
Is that you?
Is that you daddy?
Like what?
Daddy doesn't talk like that?
How dare you turn it into some sort of a joke,
but kids can't even go on.
Like when I,
anytime I'm going on a long drive,
like if I don't have podcasts,
I'm not going like I can't listen to music anymore.
I need to,
and now I got hooked on Dan Carlin's hardcore history best,
so good.
This new one,
this the one that he just put out,
he's got this,
this series out in part six just came out and it's blueprint for Armageddon.
It's all about world war one.
He was just telling me,
he's like,
Adam,
skip the Mongols.
Go to that one.
No,
don't skip the money.
The Mongols are still,
oh,
this is,
this is awesome.
It is a blueprint for Armageddon is fucking awesome.
But the Mongols is APIC.
I'm loving that.
I can't believe you've crushed it to death on here,
but like how good those guys were riding horses and shooting fucking bows and
they were like,
I could see it.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a guy named,
I think his name is Lars Anderson.
I don't know if you've heard of him before.
There's this famous on the Internet over the last uh,
year or so for developing these ancient archery techniques that were lost and he
has like looked in like these ancient texts and photos of how there's one way of
holding bows and arrows that we have today and one way that he thinks that they
did back then where they held all the arrows in their hands instead of an a
quiver.
They held them on their hands and they could literally rapid fire several hour
arrows in a second and he thinks that this might be one of the like loss
techniques that these ancient archers yous see this guy here,
Lars Anderson.
Like look how cool this guy can like shoot things that are in the air.
Like you got to see how good this guy is at this,
how quick he looked.
He throws a tennis ball and as a tennis ball bounces in the air,
look at this.
He could shoot it with fucking look good that he's shooting it with his leg is,
he's got a bunch of amazing videos where he shows all the different things that
could do.
Look with how quick he can shoot this.
He throws the air up in the air.
I mean,
it's incredible.
No,
that's insane.
He shoots things in the air before these coming down with them too.
He shot two in like a second.
And that's the bow in his left hand.
He can do the bone,
his righthand bone,
his left hand.
He can switch back and forth.
Either way.
I socket.
Yeah,
I mean,
this guy must be links to his dick because he's just gonna say,
how many hours of practice is that too?
And he just shot an arrow.
Look at this.
He's spinning this wheel and as the wheel spins,
he's shooting the arrows into the wheel.
Look at this.
He's kind of bounce off this thing.
He shot two hours before he hit the ground.
Three arrows and a half a second.
This is incredible.
I don't try this at home,
but I think,
um Oh fuck you.
Shit.
It wouldn't be.
It would be fucking amazing.
So what he's doing right now is just going to spin and shoot the Arrow in the
air.
And he dodged one there.
Will.
He shoots the Arrow in the air as it's coming towards him.
The guy shoots an Arrow and as it's coming at him,
Holy Shit.
But I think to see the Mongols and how they had done it must have been really,
it would be really amazing if someone was alive that had the kind of proficiency
that they had back then.
They would,
they would wait
until the horse was in mid.
Gallup saw all four legs were off the ground before they release the air so that
it didn't shake like he was insane when he was explaining.
I'm like,
that doesn't even seem possible.
How could people I bleed?
They were just timing.
I mean,
it seems totally possible if you could see that guy shoot three arrows and 0.6
seconds.
Oh,
I bet.
I mean,
one of my buddies that plays football,
he was talking about how they learn how to run on a treadmill to be more like a
Gallup so that they don't waste energy.
So I mean,
you could see how you could I,
he was just explaining it to me.
I hadn't,
didn't get to see it.
And he's like,
yeah,
we,
we learn how to,
so it's like you can do strides on the field so you don't burn out.
You're like,
you can learn to kind of gallop until you have to really press right and get in
there and so you can keep your momentum up.
Huh.
So it's like less,
you know,
like me,
I'm very heavy footed.
If I run a trial,
I'm like calm pom pom pom.
Right.
But there's a way to be lighter,
kind of like,
you know,
sprinters are much more on their tippy toes for a part of it.
Right,
right.
Well,
they say that you're really supposed to run on the ball.
Your feet,
like this heel running that we've all gotten accustomed to is actually the
design of running shoes and the people creating these running shoes with these
really thick heel pads.
They've actually changed the gate of runners.
Jamie,
you're a runner,
right?
That's,
do you run with a,
those kind of,
uh,
running shoes?
Uh,
yeah.
I actually use like the Nike free run.
They're actually really thin.
Not as thin as like a converse,
but pretty close to that.
It's almost like running barefoot just with the little rubber on your soul.
So you run and land on the ball of your foot and you use that to cushion.
Yeah.
It's weird switch though.
Toes work is like a little bit of a spring for you.
Yeah.
Your toes work as,
yeah,
it's like a shock absorber and if you run he'll like everybody is used to,
I was like super bad for you.
You can just feel it when you get,
you know,
I've been recently trying to get back into shape is every time we go on road
trips for filming,
we eat like Shit,
we're late hours working and you get out of whack.
Right.
It's when I get home and I can feel it.
The first couple of weeks I'm on the treadmill,
I'm heavy,
I've kind of lost my rhythm and Clonk I can feel the extra weight and my joints.
But then once you get,
I kind of get back and I'm like,
okay,
now I,
it's weird a correct and I'm not anyone professional correcting me or looking
and seeing if I have the right shoe or whatever.
But I just noticed like,
okay,
I'm starting to get my rhythm started,
pace of it better.
I'm not so he'll mang as I'm running,
well I run on the balls of my feet when I do it,
but it always feels like I'm on a,
I'm falling forward or something.
You know what I mean?
Like changes the way I'm not really feeling like a fallen for it,
but you know what I mean?
I've got like why doing this right way?
You know?
Like I feel like I'm doing something wrong when I run the real way you're
supposed to run well because your body's adapted and molded to the way that is.
So then you just go and change it.
It's like,
well you know,
similar to martial arts when you're like,
I'm a boxer stance rights.
If I was gonna go,
but that doesn't work for fighting MMA.
Right.
My stance would be side.
It's much easier for a take down.
I'd have to adapt and that'd be really awkward for me at first.
Right.
Cause is a consideration.
Leg kicks is a huge one for boxing it up there.
You have to be more,
more,
you have to stand sideways more or uh,
or uh,
parallel more.
Yeah.
It's just one of those things where,
um,
I think like if you watch kids run you a,
you kind of get a sense like,
oh this is just natural for them.
They run on the balls of their feet totally naturally.
And then we have through those weird shoes we've figured out a way to Kinda like
come up with a new way and that way it's been adopted like across the board as
people.
Like they think it's the right way.
We'll look at you.
You have young kids and I have a boy that's three and he's always falling
forward cause he's so tippy toe heavy when he runs right now.
Right?
Yeah.
And when I go to his daycare,
I see all the kids are doing like there's giant heads too.
And that's like a little kid.
Like I have a four year old head is like almost as wide as his shoulders.
He really think about how big their fucking heads are.
Imagine if you had a head that went all the way out to the side,
like one of those like,
like you are furry.
Yeah.
One of the has a mascot head on.
They fall forward.
There's too much weight.
Their weights all out of whack now my boy bales all the time cause he's too,
yeah that all the time.
But then gets right up and keeps going.
Yeah.
I think that uh,
whoever invented the running shoe with that padded heal,
it's,
it's really kind of amazing how much of an impact that it's had.
But it works when you're working your regular day job though and you're sitting
on your heels all day.
Right.
That's still bad for you.
Even though shoes,
those shoes are bad to walk around in the guys who are back experts,
spinal correction people,
they say that the issue of like changing the way you stand,
like giving yourself an inclined,
like,
because of the fact you have heels on,
like girls that wear high heels or dudes wear cowboy boots or shit like that.
It's super bad for your back.
It's like giving your back this weird sort of,
oh this is the,
that they had those,
um,
that's like those barefoot technology shoes that people were wearing for awhile.
I tried wearing those for awhile.
There were so ridiculous,
you know why I stopped wearing them?
I couldn't wear them on stage.
You know those,
what are they called?
Bt something bear for you weren't allowed to wear the ones?
No,
no,
no.
You rock.
Oh,
numb.
They have like this,
uh,
they don't have the heel.
They have like a big flat part.
Uh,
uh,
a big like thick part in the middle sort of.
And the idea is this barefoot technology is like that.
You've got to kind of,
you're constantly correcting,
cause you're kind of stepping on his odd sponge and then it gives you,
like,
you're,
you're burning off more calories and you're using your balance more in the
stupid shoes.
This is the idea behind it.
But in that I'll get debunked that it doesn't actually,
well I think sketchers,
sketchers,
there's put that up again,
Jamie.
There's some sort of a giant class action lawsuit and the Oh,
consumer injury lawsuits.
I didn't know about this.
Is this new,
Oh,
this is new because there was a class action lawsuits and now there's,
but is that for that shoe or does that for that toe shoe?
There's no,
this is a shoe with that rocker thing.
It looks ridiculous.
I'd have troubles walking.
Well it's,
it's totally ridiculous,
but it's the same exact style of shoes.
It was barefoot running technology,
shoes,
whatever the fuck they're called.
Um,
but those,
these things,
they're supposed to like,
you're supposed to be like constantly correcting,
almost like you're on a,
a,
a balanced bar or something like that.
Look at this.
If you or a loved one suffered a broken hip,
broken ankle,
stress fracture,
Achilles tendonitis,
uh,
that could be the result of wearing toning shoes like sketchers shape ups.
We want to hear from you.
You may be eligible.
All the fucking the hounds are out back.
You may be eligible to receive compensation for your medical bills,
lost wages,
pain and suffering or other damages.
What other damages could there be new?
It couldn't get laid.
Man.
Stress.
We're stupid.
Fucking shoes ruined my confidence and prevented me from getting jobs.
No girl would look at me.
I started taking mental health medication.
Yeah.
Those um,
those shoes were quite popular for awhile but I couldn't wear them on stage
cause you can't stand on your heels.
Like you're kind of rocking a little bit.
Like if you try to sit back like you can't,
like you can't like just cause you have this like,
like Hump in the center of the shoe.
Okay.
It's really,
really stupid.
I try to wear things as flat as possible with my,
my favorite shoes are chucks,
converse,
all stars.
Those are my favorite because they're super simple.
They're really flat.
There's no heel and those,
they're the best for working out too cause you can like you push off the ground,
you forgot to chose.
Yeah.
Lifting them or barefoot.
I like to lift barefoot but if I'm a home I lift barefoot.
Yeah.
If I'm at a gym they make you worse than you have to wear shoes.
Cause cause that little thin layer is going to help you if you drop an 80 pound
dumbbell on there.
Right.
That will save your toe?
I guess it probably help a little,
you know,
I remember,
I think it might help the cop because I don't think it will help the bone,
but it might help you split it open.
I just,
it's just strange that like this style of shoe like this is,
these aren't Chuck's,
but there's the same thing really.
Fin Soul that suppo flat.
No,
no fat cushion on the bottom.
Like those running shoes with the fact cushion.
The heel supposed to be really bad for you I suppose,
but not like also a wallet in your back pocket.
It's supposed to be really bad.
I have a,
I can get Stan's a wall but I put it in my,
in my,
I was wearing like a sports coat so I can put it in the side pocket.
There are people gonna know to pickpocket you.
Adam's Gorgie.
They can't get it out.
I'll tell you,
it'll get stuck if they try to.
I switched to one of these recently and minimalist wallet.
It's just a little tiny one that I put my front pocket credit cards.
I have a fanny pack still haven't give up on that way.
Never giving up.
Not giving that up.
It's the best thing.
I traveled too much.
It's the best thing for travel.
I put it on everything is always right there in the front.
I have to reach in my pockets on airplanes and everything and then when I go
through the Tsa I just click put that sucker in the basket.
Makes Sense,
ethic click,
put it right back on and we're off.
It does make sense when you break it down that way.
So I'm always thinking brother,
always thinking,
always breaking shit down.
I'd write it.
I just don't understand how the fanny pack got out of favor.
I just,
I I refuse.
I refuse to accept it.
Never had one satchels.
People in their saturate.
It makes perfect.
Next your carry on for you.
It's like an extra little bag,
right when you were thinking,
I was like,
actually I might have to,
I haven't had to have to rock one of these for my product because I had my
passports and like my green card and everything and then you've got like for us
to cross with film gear,
we have to get like a,
they're called pocket letters,
so that shows that it Canadian production is hiring Canadian workers.
We're not taking American jobs or just simply interviewing American subjects and
so I have to have all that documentation and a car ne for equipment to show that
we're not selling at our equipment that we're bringing down and the whole works.
So it having that would actually be pretty handy where I could have like all my
stuff in there and just take it off.
You go through the,
the belt.
I had this one lady,
only one lady ever on a plane tell me that that was a bag and adapt bag.
Had to either be put in another bag or tucked under my seat and I go,
what are you talking about?
It's a pocket.
That's in the front.
It's just not attached to my pants.
She's like,
it's back,
sir.
I go,
it's a fanny pack,
fanny pack disconnect though.
She made me stuff it in my backpack.
Are you really gonna make me take this off and put it in my backpack for takeoff
and landing?
You have to take all back one lady.
I've been on a million flights.
This has never happened.
It's so ridiculous to me when someone tries to get the gold star.
When you go that you can travel a ton,
like same airline and everything and then one day someone else is like,
yeah,
I tried to target as always I'm filming so I just don't want any reason.
Especially if I'm going,
if I'm going in Canada,
I'll argue a bit more,
but if I'm going to the United States,
we have a chance to not let me in.
I just go,
yeah,
no problem.
No problem.
I might want to go to Canada or anywhere in the world.
I'm just fuck yes sir.
No Sir.
Yep,
no problem.
The other guy pulled me out of line last time I went to Canada.
It was,
well,
it was on my way to do the UFC.
It was kind of interesting.
The guy,
um,
he w what is it called?
Not Pattern you,
uh,
what does it called?
Oh,
randomly select.
Not Randomly selected.
What is it called when I'm like,
we'll do you target someone of Middle Eastern descent,
you know,
like what is that called?
Oh,
profile profile.
You,
Yep.
Yeah.
So I'm,
the guy looked at me and he goes,
come here,
sir.
I talked to you for a second.
And like,
out of nowhere there's a line of people are looking and everybody goes,
you're pretty big guy.
What do you do?
You know,
like,
like what do I do?
Like,
what are you talking about?
What do I do?
What did I do wrong?
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
what are you here for?
I go,
I worked for the ultimate fighting championship.
He goes,
oh,
what's up Joe?
Like,
and then he was killing it.
But I was like,
but if you wasn't cool with me,
you know,
like he had decided,
he looked at me like,
what are you bringing in steroids or something?
And you lifting weights,
you got any rocks in that fucking backpack?
Yeah,
like it was like,
it was like he,
I didn't do anything wrong.
You know,
I had all my paperwork and I had my passport and I had gone through and the
guy's like,
come here sir.
I talked to you for a moment.
Like he did not recognize me.
I had like,
I had a vortex hat on and I'll like fucking just,
I was just looked like a normal dude,
but for
whatever reason,
I don't know if he decided like we're going to like target people look like they
lift weights or people who look like they might be shady.
I got,
I got flagged for awhile where I was pulled every time I went to Vancouver
airport because one time I was leaving is weird.
My wife had gotten me new bag.
It came with like,
she bought me some Cologne and then it came,
it was a Calvin Klein bag late,
just a duffel bag that came with the Cologne.
So I packed my stuff.
It was like a two day trip to New York was when I was first doing the union.
I was looking for Cruz and I was interviewing producers and stuff like that and
it was just a quick trip.
But then I came back and then they pulled me aside and then they tested my bag
and they're like,
your bag is tested positive for cocaine.
And I was like,
what?
I was like,
bullshit.
show it to me.
I was like,
I didn't know understand at the time.
And they're like,
we found cocaine all over your bag.
I'm like,
bullshit.
Let me see it.
There's no cocaine in my bag.
And they said,
no,
no.
What?
Like we tested it.
There's particles.
Why would it be on there?
Do you do cocaine?
I'm like,
never in my life.
Not even tried.
It know like,
well how is it all over your bag?
I'm like,
I have no idea.
And then so we went in the back for hours and they're chill.
They're like,
Hey,
quit playing this game.
We talked to your friend.
I'm like,
good.
Well,
he would have told you the same thing.
So I was traveling with a friend.
I was like,
he would have told you the same thing.
Good cop,
bad cop.
He's like,
he told us the drill and I was like,
what?
Yeah,
that we went to New York,
we're looking at developing a documentary and then it finally came down to where
I said,
okay,
like tell me how this particle thing works.
Because I did the night deposit for my nightclub the night before.
Right.
And they say a large majority of money,
especially in nightclubs and stuff.
I asked cocaine on it,
right.
People do a rail wipe their hand grabbed the bill.
And I had done the cash deposit for the nightclub right before our flight.
I'd put it in that bag,
went to the night deposit,
put it in the bank,
and then I flew out to like six or seven in the morning and like pack my gear
instead of,
so I said,
could it be that like cocaine was on the money that was in,
in my bag that,
and they're like,
yes,
we can trace particles like that.
And I'm like,
well then there's your answer.
But then they looked at my club,
strip club,
cheetahs,
this and that.
And then there,
then it was just like we were in there longer and I was like,
oh.
So every time I came back,
and here's the interesting thing is every time I came back to Vancouver,
they flagged,
they'd pull me aside,
pulled me,
and finally I was so mad.
I was like one in the morning.
I was like,
please just don't pull me aside.
I'm so tired.
I got to drive to the outskirts of Vancouver to stay at my buddy's place.
I just want to go to bed.
It's a medic three and please go to the side.
I'm like,
so I was so mad.
I just laid on their metal counter.
I was tired.
Neck,
cause you know they do the thing where they put you over there.
Then nobody comes for like half hour,
just make you sit there.
So I just laid,
I started napping.
It was exhausted like one 30 in the morning,
coming back from New York.
I laid up there and the girl comes to get down.
I'm like,
I'm tired.
It's one 30 in the morning.
I'm really tired and I'm not playing any games.
Like she and I finally just said,
why am I getting pulled over all the time?
I've never broken a law.
You can't like,
there's nothing every check your thing.
I've never done anything.
I've never brought over items that I shouldn't.
I have meet and she's like,
well,
the big problem is,
is that one time your bag got tested.
I was like,
I explained that and that should all be in the notes,
right?
She said,
yeah,
but we always don't trust it when you say you don't do the product right and
it's all over your bag because then we think you're a smuggler.
She's like,
you're almost better to just say,
Yup,
I did some cocaine with friends or whatever and we don't have any on me.
And I was like,
but I don't.
I don't do it.
I'm not
going to say I did it.
And she's like,
well,
that's why they think you're maybe a smuggler.
You're doing quick trips to New York.
It's on your bag.
Well,
it's like the guy who got in trouble for structuring the same,
you did it similar to what it is we're going to take.
Your money was just cash that they have a bunch of different techniques that
they teach these knuckleheads to try to like recognize shady people and so they
like think they're fucking spies are like think they're detectives staring at
everybody.
I'm done.
I don't know about that.
Jamie Vernon and look at his face.
I,
I saw a deceptive tips her and I immediately pulled out of the line.
I actually got the guy really pissed off when it,
cause I used to get,
these were the Canadian guys and I'm a Canadian so I was like you can't kick me
out of my own country.
So I battle with them a little bit harder.
And the one guy asked me,
he's like,
have you ever done a narcotic?
And I was like,
no,
never done it.
Narcotic.
He's like,
if you never smoked weed,
I'm like that's not a narcotic.
Narcotic comes from the Latin word,
meaning narcosis causing asleep and do state,
which is usually applied to opiates and heroin and stuff like that.
I was like,
marijuana is a psycho tropical drawing.
I think he was just like,
it's like a trophy psycho tropic,
right?
That's tropical.
It's like a,
it's part of the world.
And uh,
and he was just like,
let's not get to the nitty gritty.
And I said,
no,
no.
You're a border guard.
You're asking me questions.
I'm answering honestly.
So if you're going to ask me questions,
you make sure you answer the,
you asked me the right one and I will give you the correct answer.
And he was like,
go.
You can go.
That's the difference.
You Canadians and Americans,
Americans there.
Fuck this guy.
Canadians are more willing to admit the feet.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I just think that the whole border thing is fucking ridiculous.
It's really ridiculous.
Well,
I'd had that debate with want them too.
I'm like giving,
you guys know what your stopped like the big guys smuggle hundreds of tons,
like through transport ships.
I've got one carry on.
How much you getting today?
Know how few of those transport boxes ever get checked off when you look at
those gigantic freighter ships and they're just covered in those boxes.
The vast majority of those boxes never get search.
We'll look at Howard marks from our film,
the cannabis smuggler from the UK.
He was a great,
by the way,
genius way to put it in there.
But he's like,
I made deals with the road manager of Pink Floyd Genesis cause he's like,
of course,
even if they did the testing back then they're like,
it's a band.
Of course there's weed and stuff like that.
And he put it all in there and smuggled it across.
Yeah.
Hash right side.
Those speakers and the all the,
the reason school allege equipment.
Yeah.
Where's that guy now?
Where does he live?
Actually on four.
He's still in the UK.
Can't really leave the UK I don't think.
But he just got diagnosed with uh,
an operable a colon cancer.
So he's taken a turn.
He's bald now,
going through things going on,
kind of a last tour and there's a doc being done specifically just on him.
And his and his role.
But,
uh,
I mean,
a brilliant character.
I'd love watching the theater,
but he's laughing when he's on.
He's hilarious.
He's got great charisma.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the things that I thought was really hilarious about him was he said that
if he could do it today,
he's like,
I crack it off.
He's like,
I mean,
I loved it.
Great.
Such a great,
honest answer.
And he's just like,
he's like,
I suppose if I could get away with it,
I'd crack it up today.
And they loved it.
Well,
it sounds like he was having a ball,
a ball.
He left it.
He was like a rocker,
like,
and he,
uh,
he,
he and then spend,
the other part that's funny too is when he talks about the DEA and he's like,
they say it was 50 tons,
but I know of course your transporter,
you know what you're getting and receiving.
It's like,
I know it was only 30 tons.
I know how much I was making off of that.
He's,
he was amazing.
He was an amazing part of that.
He,
that's just so important to recognize how silly this whole war on drugs has been
and how ineffective this whole trucks has been and that these guys who were the
enemy or these charismatic,
really hilarious,
nice people that actually spent lots of time and effort to try to change the
laws that we asked them where like you were making a profit on it though.
It wasn't.
He's like,
ah,
I just feel that it'd be like a rocker.
I was only going to last so long and kind of just do it as long as I could until
I went down.
Right.
What's next?
So you're going to do another documentary on we actually,
we've got not on weed,
Colorado,
we're done on weed.
I've got a two in the works right now.
We actually just got one approved,
but Robbie Knievel called chasing evil.
Oh Wow.
That we're looking on all about how he was chasing his father's legacy and then
ultimately surpassed it.
And then his own father like actually was like threatened by his son rivaling
his thing.
So it became,
comes pretty dark.
Um,
and then also another one that I've been working on for years to get the
financing together.
It's a ice guardians all about the role of NHL enforcers in the history of
fighting and hockey and how now it's being weaned out of the game where it
started,
why it evolved over the years.
It's called the pussification of the world.
Adam's fluoridation of America.
Yeah.
Why are they taking fighting out of hockey?
How dare they,
you take away finding on a hockey,
you know,
where you got figure skating with the top with a black ticktack.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's some very interesting uh,
dynamics that plays into it cause such a fast game and you're on a foreign
surface with razor blades on your feet and sticks and you know,
a lot of the pro,
because we didn't just say interview tough guys.
We're interviewing superstars and stuff too,
right?
That said like,
look,
I played my best games when I knew there wasn't a chance that guy was going to
lift a stick and hit me in the eye or throwing elbows going to be concussion.
He's like,
yeah,
he can get suspended or get a fine,
but nothing is more intimidating than when you have a six foot six killer that
he comes and leans over your shoulder and says if you play reckless like that
again,
I'm calming.
Right?
So intimidation where it's a,
it's a fascinating dynamic that's been argued like kind of like the marijuana
thing where there's always the,
you know,
black and white,
but there's so many other nuances to it.
And for me the story,
I thought that's always been missed as these guys are amazing charismatic guys
that were so selfless,
willing to fight on ice,
bare knuckle,
no weight class to make their dreams of playing in the NHL come true and protect
their teammates.
That part has always been lost in the argument is how selfless they were.
And you want to talk about humility.
I kind of compare it to what you and Eddie Bravo of talking about Jujitsu where
it's like the Douche bag eliminator,
right?
Like someone comes in on the biggest baddest and you get like the 16 year old to
Pretzel m three times.
Well with the enforcers,
they've all been where they've been knocked out or they've lost a fight or
something.
So they're humble.
His Shit,
they don't know any given day.
Their career can end.
They get sent to the minors.
They does happen to those guys.
They get beat up real bad too.
And they're never the same,
never the same mentally or they get knocked out and then they have kids.
So the humility of them there,
some of the greatest athletes I've met,
like getting to work with these guys.
Perfect example.
We interviewed a guy that won a Stanley Cup with the kings.
Um,
he was a Princeton graduate.
Kevin Westgarth graduated with a degree in psychology,
super intellectual guy.
And in college they don't allow the fighting,
right?
They don't have fighting and they were full cages,
uh,
instead of open visor or open mass.
So he got drafted to the NHL to play for the kings and they wanted that physical
presence that he bought.
He brought and he got knocked out in a game and uh,
against,
uh,
it was like two years ago in Calgary and we asked them like,
what was the first thing that went through your head like when you woke up and
realized like you're in front of 16,000 people,
hundreds of thousands of people on hockey night in Canada.
I've been watching and this part almost brought us all to tears when he was
like,
well,
once I realized where I was and what happened,
I was like,
shit,
he got me.
He's like,
and then the next thing I realized is like,
wow,
I let my team down.
I was like,
so injury knocked out everything.
The first thing you're thinking about is that you let your team down.
And he's like,
yeah,
he's like,
I really,
you know,
I'm supposed to be the guy there that they depend on.
That's the backbone to give them,
you know,
strength and everything else.
And I had let my team down and several of these guys had said that and that
selflessness that they're willing to give to their team to help them win.
That to me is so much more,
you know,
when you're going through the journey of a documentary,
so much more compelling than just a statistical arguments and stuff like that.
Yeah.
I always wonder like when you see violence in Nho or football or I wonder how
much longer that's going to be a part of society.
It's interesting.
It's very interesting how like it's but I,
but then you have seized,
never been more popular.
Right.
Um,
there's arguments that it's,
it's oversaturated.
Um,
I disagree.
I think it's just,
I think there,
what there is is there's ebbs and flows and it's depending upon a bunch of
factors.
Dominant Champions,
champions get dethroned.
There's new guys coming up.
They,
but they don't have the same like Chris Weidman,
although he beat Anderson Silva twice better than Anderson Silva.
Arguably it's especially today,
still doesn't have the name that Anderson Silva had.
George Saint Pierre sort of same thing.
Robbie Lawler,
who is currently the champ doesn't have the name that George had,
although,
you know,
he'd probably be favored if George and Robby fought today.
Robbie would probably be favorite.
I think George is far more popular and that's just one of those things.
Brock Lesnar.
Yeah,
Cain Velasquez does not have the popularity that Brock Lesnar had obviously in a
different reason because for different reasons,
because he was the WWE champ and big pro wrestling is very loud and spoken and
like he was almost a perfect villain.
Right.
You wanted to see him lose because of his,
some of his antics and the way I like,
I'm a ridiculous fan.
I watch all the time.
So yeah,
me too.
I get what you're saying.
Like GSP in Canada.
I mean you're talking about like God,
they're right.
Yeah.
But not even just in Canada,
all throughout the world.
I mean he has so many characteristics,
so many character traits.
Just he was an honorable martial artist who is a great fighter.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what he is.
And a well spoken guy and just so classy,
like everything about him.
He's just a,
he's a brilliant person.
Well,
and that's why I think some of the other fighters may not have,
is that,
I mean you had the full package with GSP,
right?
Like physically,
he looked astonishing too.
Right?
Like if you were to look,
you're like,
oh wow,
I can see,
oh he's a champion.
Like he's ripped.
He's this very polite.
Always like after a fight I want to give my guy at credit.
I know he'll be back stronger and more competitive next time.
Like that's much more marketable.
Other guys,
you know,
don't have like Cain Velasquez I love and I think he's a destroyer but he's much
more monotone.
Like he doesn't have,
I think that would have been fine if he didn't get injured so much.
I think what's held came back is he's only fought a few times over the last four
years.
He just keeps getting injured.
Shoulder surgery,
knee surgery.
I mean he's had one after the other.
He's had several knee injuries,
stroke,
two separate shoulder operations on both shoulders.
I mean his mental toughness and his drive is,
and the,
the training routine that those guys go through is just so unfucking believably
brutal that his body just can't keep up.
That's I was going to take,
cause he puts a pace for a heavyweight that you just can't,
I mean lightweights can't put the pace that he puts on.
Like he really does.
I get exhausted watching him.
He out conditions guys when they like guys who train at Aka,
you'll talk about he all conditions Walter weights and they can't believe it.
He all conditioned some of the 155 pounders.
It's crazy.
I mean he's moving around a hundred more pounds and somehow or another he can
keep up with them and surpass them.
He's a freak.
But I think the,
the injuries is what has held him back from being insanely popular because he's
huge in the Mexican community.
Yeah.
He's gonna fight in Mexico.
They're fighting for breezy ober doom.
That's what I was fight.
It's going to raid fight in June and uh,
I can't wait to see that fight.
And that's going to be in Mexico City,
which is going to be really crazy cause they're fighting that.
I think it's 7,000 feet above sea level who very high altitude a Mexico City is
no joke when it comes to altitude,
like you really feel it.
Well,
I know even we go to park city.
My family as I was in Park City in Utah,
the elevation up there,
my dad,
I thought my dad was having a heart attack the first time we went skiing.
He fell off.
The first round was panting.
He was like,
Oh my God,
are you okay?
And he says,
Oh,
I think the elevate,
like I'm having troubles breathing.
And then after a few runs we kind of got a little bit adjusted.
But it was interesting to see.
I was like,
wow,
I can't imagine in fighting like that.
Just going down skiing like yes,
it's physical,
but not like,
not like competing in in any kind of fight game.
Did you ever see Mark Hunt versus Ben Rothwell?
There was a fight that took place in Denver.
Yes.
Yes I did.
Dulles is guys.
We're so tired,
so tired.
They were just like swinging from their shoulder joints by the [inaudible].
I mean it was all will and heart and after a certain point in time,
there's just no energy left.
And we've never had like a real long heavyweight fight at high altitude other
than that fight.
I think this,
this last one between Fabrizio for doom and Mark Hunt ended in the second round
for resale,
caught him with a knee.
But like they get into like a junior dos Santos versus Cain Velasquez type
fight.
Those fights were fucking Burger UDL.
I don't think it's ever been the same since then.
Um,
I don't think he hasn't either.
Seems to have effect,
didn't get really sick from like overtraining.
And one of them it was he fought in the second fight,
he had what they called Rhabdomyolysis,
which is what those crossfit people think I'm saying it right.
Yeah,
yeah.
That,
um,
that comes from your body just overtrained to the point where your kidneys are
breaking down and failing and they're feeding on your own muscle.
Right.
As an awful,
yeah.
It's awful.
Deaths just,
it was just such an unbelievably brutal fight.
So I think it was that and it was also the fact,
the,
the brutality of the fight itself and then also perhaps overtraining to prepare
for Keynes,
insane cardio,
you know,
because cane just,
he brings it on a level that and a lot of it that they,
according to the guys that train with them as genetic,
like he can just take three or four weeks off like get injured,
come back,
outwork everybody.
Well you can,
I compare and it might very limited boxing career but when you talk about,
I hear you talking about like you can't train power,
right?
Like that's something like there's genetic aspects and the way your body and
train a certain amount of power,
certain amount of power.
Yeah.
Like um,
George Foreman type power when I either have or you don't,
when I box,
that was one thing.
I was very young.
I was 15 at one 35 but I mean at that weight I hit really hard,
right straight,
right hand.
It was really by the end of my sparring partners,
they'd only put me in with 25 year olds because they are worried that if I lost
my temper I might hurt the next of 15 year olds.
Right.
Like not trying to sound like a Herculean,
but just that was my,
you know,
for me that came instantly.
The first time I started learning focus paths for me that was there.
It was,
the problem with that is,
um,
uh,
with a lot of folks is that they rely on that and they don't develop the skills
like the guys like a Wayne McCullough or like a guy who doesn't necessarily have
brutal one punch knockout power.
Even Julio Cesar Chavez,
arguably one of the greatest of all time.
It didn't have that vicious one punch power,
but he just would go at you with accumulation of perfectly placed punches.
I would bet on that.
Anytime that like that better conditioning will cause it really like when we're
going back to the mental thing,
like especially if a power puncher,
if you fight guy that just,
he's
not going down and he's got the Chin and you hit and like you said,
then you're overcoming,
you're like,
okay,
wow,
this guy might have to actually like outlast him condition wise and start being
late.
Like then all of a sudden you already start second guessing yourself and you're
losing.
You're like,
oh shit.
Like I saw it in the showtime Pettis,
the last fight when he got caught in the eye.
Right.
And he took it for who is the Brazilian that he fought his hospital dos Hondros
I thought I saw it then I was like,
wow,
he looks like he might be second guessing himself right now.
He's like,
holy,
I can't get space from this guy.
I can't,
I can't impose my will.
And once that mind starts turning that you start second guessing like is my,
I had it in the ring,
my loss where it was like,
Aye.
God,
what?
Because I was living relying too much of my power.
Didn't train enough and then got beat.
Same
thing with Jujitsu as well.
Um,
the WWE,
I always tell people if you really want to learn Jujitsu,
right?
Learn it from a small guy cause small guys rely on perfect technique.
Like,
um,
if you look at like the really big physically strong guys that are good at
Jujitsu,
there's a totally different style that they have in like say a Beret Yoshida or
a boiler Gracie or an Eddie Bravo or you know,
there's a bunch of those guys that are smaller guys that have Leo Vieira perfect
technique and you need perfect technique when you're physically smaller person
because when you're in the gym,
if you go like you go to John Joc Machado's Jujitsu Academy or whatever,
you're,
you're going to roll with a bunch of different people.
Like somebody might roll with you.
You're probably like,
what,
215 pounds or something like that to 10.
I've come down a little bit.
Or you might roll with Jamie who's probably like one 70 right?
What's that one 75 some of that.
What you've been in.
What I'm saying like there's,
and you know if you're a small person like no,
if I got,
if I weigh 150 pounds,
I'm not going to out muscle you.
I have to figure out a way to work around you.
I have to figure out a way to get your back or I have to figure out a way to use
technique only because I can't overpower you,
but you can overpower a lot of people and big man Jujitsu is kind of Shitty
Jujitsu because big managers always trying to force their way into things.
A lot of wrestlers have that as well because wrestlers are used to fighting guys
in their weight class.
They used to,
or wrestling rather guys in their way class and they used to just go just
grinding and full power and speed and explosion and be a harder worker and all
that stuff.
Whereas with Jujitsu it's about moving around it and,
and it's all about the chess game.
Well,
it's just about understanding technique and positioning.
And if you learn from like a Guy Mendez or something like that,
the Mendez brothers are famous for being small guys who would just tap much
larger guys on a regular basis.
And it's just that pure technique.
Understanding the leverage,
understanding the positions.
And you only get that from being smaller.
And I think if you look at a guy like Floyd Mayweather,
Floyd Mayweather has a bunch of knockouts in his career,
but he just does not have the kind of one punch knockout power.
A lot of other fighters do.
Even Combo knockout power.
He doesn't have it,
but he will also also,
he's so fucking smart.
Even when it comes to boxing,
he's so fucking smart that he realizes the most important thing is don't get
hit.
That is the most important thing.
Well for your health and for scoring and for the whole work,
for everything.
I mean what he does to people's shuts all their offense down.
You just can't hit him.
He's moving.
He's popping you with the jam.
He's popping in with the right hand.
He's clinching,
he's getting the fuck out of the way and he's not going to stand toe to toe and
dig his heels in and try to swing with you.
Like some fighters would do like some fighters who would make things exciting,
you know,
like a Micky ward or an Arturo Gotti.
Like those two guys make it together and fucking go to war while it like Ray
Ray,
man CNE,
that was his style,
right.
Is that he could out condition condition will you,
he array actually was really disappointed that they took away the championship
rounds like after his fight cause boxing made a ruling to try to,
it wasn't just his fight,
it was a compound of a few other things,
but they no longer had fights pass the 12 round.
Right.
And Ray,
he's like,
I guess like he's saying the science doesn't show that you take any more damage
in those rounds.
And in the first rounds when a guy strong and crisp,
right?
Like you can still deliver the same amount.
And for ray he's like,
that was,
those were my best rounds.
Like when you would tire and you'd almost want to give up or you're Wilwood
brake a little bit.
He's like 12 like 13 1415 that's when I'm coming on strongest.
Right.
Let's see if you really have what it takes to be a champion.
Would you see that with some guy like mighty mouse?
Demetrius Johnson,
he's a perfect example of technique.
Mighty mouse is the 125 pound UFC champion and a guy,
in my opinion,
who's the best overall pound for pound fighter ever.
That's why the light,
he's thinking that he's not like,
I mean I'm a fan so I know who he,
but why do you think he's not as made?
Like not as known,
like in some ways 125 pounds.
Just the size that I'm five eight and when I interview him in the Octagon,
I looked like a giant,
you know,
he's a small guy.
It just,
there's just no getting around that.
It's just there's a reality of physics and you know,
people just,
they want to see,
look,
in his last fight,
he finished the fight with one second to go in the fifth round of a fight.
He was totally dominating.
He went for an arm bar and got it with one second to go against her Gucci.
Who's this bad ass mother fucker horror Gucci's a maniac,
you know,
he fights,
he's got this wild aggressive style.
Couldn't,
couldn't hit Demetrius.
He's just so good.
He's so slick.
And he's,
he epitomizes the technique,
the technique and knowledge and strategy angle of fighting everything he does,
his technique,
knowledge and strategy.
He's not overpowering anybody or muscling or taking one to give one,
none of that nonsense.
There's zero that nonsense going on.
So my opinion,
like when I look at like,
you know,
people say,
well Jon Jones is the best.
We'll certainly one of the best.
Like we got a tiny is there,
you know,
but that's him making weight though.
He'll gain a little bit of weight after that too.
It's pretty octagon.
He's very sucked
in there,
which is also an unfortunate aspect of fighting.
Oh,
and also an interesting aspect like with duck who Kim,
they started making way into the day before,
which they didn't during that fight.
And another interesting thing is that almost all the deaths that have happened
in boxing,
a vast majority of like serious injuries came from guys who cut a significant
amount of weight.
And when you cut that weight,
you put your brain at risk apparently because you dehydrate everything and it
takes a long time to rehydrate your brain fluid and spinal fluid and all that
stuff.
When you're,
when you're sucking yourself dry,
you're taking,
you can't spit like people don't know what it's like.
It's hard.
It's a horrible idea.
For one of my body that was actually the fight I lost was when I really depleted
myself and was spitting in a cup and putting us a garbage bag over and skipping
and running.
And wrestlers constantly do that.
I mean they brutalize their body doing that.
And what's the difference to wrestling and fighting though of course is that
when you were wrestling re dehydrated,
you're not getting kicked in the head.
You know when you're kicked in the head might actually,
well I wouldn't think it's better but at least it'll be quick.
You know you get kicked in the head,
it's over quick.
Instead of taking a barrage of punishment.
You mean you see some fights where they go on for 10 rounds of just a beat down,
Dum,
Dum and then finally the guy will collapse and the 10th round and you're like
how much can the brain take?
So how much and especially a brain that has already been significantly weakened
by dehydrating.
I hate dehydration and fighting.
I think it's the number one problem with the UFC has other than,
you know,
some some issues with like different rules and knees on the ground as a few
other issues.
But I think the number one safety issue is dehydration and I don't know how to
stop it because people are always going to try to get that competitive edge.
You would have to like get everyone together and say,
can we just make an agreement where we just fight at the weight that we are?
You know you're going to have when you want to fucking guy fucked that up.
Even if you did,
if a midriff 90% of the fighters are on,
you're going to have a few of those guys that no doubt.
No doubt.
I mean,
um,
what's interesting with the head check is ray,
I talked like raising great shape.
How's he doing now?
Like mentally fine.
He had a cat scan.
He's like,
like he talks a little,
he talks a lot,
but his dad did the same thing where they just talk with their animated and
their hands.
His voice sounds a little,
it's a little slurry.
It times when he,
it's funny when you put them like,
cause when we toured the film and you'd go to festivals and stuff and you get in
front,
he speaks immaculately.
Right?
It's excited.
Yeah.
But when you kind of just hanging out sometimes it kind of stutters a little
bit,
but give him a couple of beers.
He says that he's,
he's had a scan and he said he's like,
no,
no bad scar tissue and stuff like that.
But he was credible.
He was very good at,
as soon as he ended his career though,
he didn't even spar.
Like,
cause I asked him like,
Oh,
do you still work out?
And he's like,
yeah,
I still hit the bag and run them.
Like,
do you can get,
no,
no.
He's like,
I put all my wars when I competed.
As soon as I stopped.
No more sparring.
I don't care if it's a friend that wants to like done good for headshots were
over right.
We'll sugary Leonard is kind of the same way.
Sugar Ray Leonard.
Uh,
you know,
you could tell there's a little loss there.
There's a little struggle with sugar.
Ray Leonard has to talk about things.
They pretty well,
there's a little,
there's a little hitch in his step as opposed to when he was younger.
But you know,
as far as the amount of fights that guy had championship fights against guys
like Tommy Hearns,
Marvin Hagler.
I mean Roberto Duran,
he fought some of the best of the best to get through that and be,
uh,
regularly functioning man in his fifties.
Then there's also depression is a bunch of things that go along with head trauma
that we're starting to find out about that man.
If they could figure out a way to mitigate that or,
or,
or fix it once it's become an issue because it's one of the few things at once
the function is compromised,
there's really not much they can do about it.
They can repair your shoulder,
you know.
Well he's saying,
cause you talk about Alpha brain a lot and wasn't the original guy that started
looking into new tropics,
like a football player that had a whole bunch of no,
he's definitely not the original guy.
Bill Romanowski but that's how I found out about it.
He has a great product that you could buy right now it's called neuro one and
neuro one.
Um,
I found out there was used to be the show in San Francisco,
um,
uh,
called,
Sarah,
no name on Alice.
There was a radio station called Alice and I would do the radio station all the
time and no name was the,
one of the DJ's.
He was friends with Roman Romanowski would train them and take them to work out
with them and stuff.
And Roman Ascii gave him this tub of this stuff that he had called neuro one to
give him some like some sample packs to give away.
And I took it and I was like,
Whoa,
this stuff has got something in it,
man.
And he was like,
it's for brain function.
I was like,
well,
what does it do?
And he goes,
and then he explained it to me.
And then I,
there was,
I don't even think there was Google at the time.
So that's like ancient.
We're talking about the olden days.
Oh yeah.
Well this is when I was doing morning radio.
I haven't done morning radio and along.
I occasionally do it,
but I used to do it for every Gig I did.
I'd have to do morning radio to promote the GIG.
So I,
um,
I go and start looking up,
uh,
do various things in nootropics.
And I found out about Paratha Tim and all of that was how we eventually got into
developing Alpha brain.
But neuro one Roman ASCII developed because he was having issues with his
cognitive function after a series of concussions.
I mean playing in the NFL,
who knows how many times that guy got concussed.
I mean it's just up in the air,
but so he,
you know,
he took a proactive approach to dealing with it and um,
built up this line of products and what does it,
they get like an Alpha brain in that one.
Are there any benefits?
Kind of like a,
like just a vitamin if you take it on a regular basis for people that have had
head trauma can make things like,
I know it's not area Miracle Hill that's going to correct it,
but I wouldn't even want to speculate quite honestly.
I mean,
I take it all the time,
but I take it from memory.
I take it for Brett.
Brett like raves about it when he was writing the culture high,
like that was part of that.
He's like,
Adam,
you need to get me out for brain.
I'm writing like he
for him,
that's his thing.
He's like,
when I'm writing and being creative,
he wants Elf brand.
Turn it us a dummy into a smart personnel.
But what it,
what it will do is it gives you,
you know,
human neuro transmitters,
this is obviously coming from a,
an untrained on educated monkey when you hear me talk,
but human neurotransmitter's essentially everything that your body has,
right?
And your body is developed based on the building blocks that you put into it.
Nutritional building blocks.
I mean,
that's the only thing your body takes in.
Other than that,
it can't,
you literally can't replicate all the cells in your body without food and
nutrition.
I mean,
that's,
that's literally what it's there for.
And it,
the more healthy precursors for neuro transmitters are more healthy foods.
The more healthy nutrients you take into your body,
the better your body functions,
period.
And they've isolated a bunch of different nutrients that can help your brain
function better.
And it is not just the stuff that's an Alpha brain.
If you just Google new tropics,
you know,
and I try to be as even about this as possible because even though I'm a part of
on it and I sell it,
I want,
I want everybody to understand like this isn't Voodoo.
It's not snake oil.
It's not the,
the Boston Center for memory that did the tests on Alpha brain is a very well
respected institution.
We brought them to separate double blind placebo controlled studies.
The one was a pilot study that was 20 people than other one was 63 people and
bolt of them showed improvements in memory improvements and executive function
improvements in reaction time.
And it's,
it's not Mumbo jumbo.
It's all based on what does your body need to produce human neurotransmitters.
There's certain nutrients take those nutrients.
Your body will produce human neuro transmitters more effective.
What is the benefit?
The benefit is you don't have to search for words as much.
You have a,
you'll have better cognitive function and you react to things quicker.
You'll have better react.
I mean,
it makes perfect sense.
I know.
Just basically when we go on road trips and we're shooting and we're working
long hours and you're trying to get to interviews,
cause when you know you're doing interviews for docs,
they're free interview.
So it's on those persons time we set up and then we're trying to make
theatrical.
So you got to set up the light.
They're long days and we go eat leg shit and I'm crushing energy drinks and so I
feel it at the end of the week.
Like my body's like,
what are you doing to yourself?
Right?
Then when I get back and I start eating like,
you know,
good fishes and vegetables and protein,
then I'm like,
oh,
now I feel better and sleep.
Very few
things as important as sleep.
I mean you,
you need all those nutrients,
but if you take all those nutrients and you're not giving your body a chance to
utilize them and recover and rest you,
you're not going to have the benefits.
There's a guy we had on Dr. Andrew Hill who has a product that I really liked
too,
called true brain and uh,
he gave us somewhere at the studio.
I like that as well.
It's a different formula than Alpha brain,
but there's a bunch of these different formulas.
You could find a bunch of them online experiment,
try it out.
Well we tried to do with Alpha brain is make it as ethical as possible so like
if you take,
this is a 30 pill count.
If you take this,
you got 90 days.
If at 90 days you say this stuff is bullshit,
it's not doing anything.
You get a 100% of your money back.
You don't even have to return the package.
And the only reason why we did that is cause like what is the best way to ensure
that no one is going to complain about being ripped off.
But still people,
I was,
I was going to say people probably still found a way,
yo.
Yeah man.
People,
people get angry but they're always going to be angry at everything you use.
If you don't believe in nootropics,
don't buy him,
that's fine.
But if you look Google it or if you just go to the Onnit website and read all
the research on Alpha brain,
read all the references.
If you don't think that there's something in all that that didn't just walk away
from it,
but if you,
if you're interested like you know and peoples who it's not worth it.
It,
to me,
cognitive function is one of the most important things to me.
The weight,
the,
the quality of my thinking,
the way my brain works.
I've experienced DL thinking,
I've been disappointed in my thinking.
I've been disappointed in my process and I've also been like,
Ooh,
I'm on right now.
This is great.
I'm getting things done and I try to steer towards anything that gets me to the
Amon and the nutrition is the biggest one for me.
Without a doubt.
The biggest factor in how my brain functions is eating a lot of vegetables and
eating healthy foods and keeping away from shitty foods,
keeping away from sugar.
If I do all that,
I guarantee I feel,
I know I feel a difference.
I feel the difference the way my brain functions.
I'm the same way,
but when we travel sometimes it gets tough and then easily,
so most hard.
I need to start getting some of your nature box snacks.
That's what I need to start hooking up.
Those are those,
which is free fruit too.
You know when you're on the road to go to a supermarket,
you know if you're on the road supermarket,
you can go,
go to the fruit aisle,
get some apples,
get some oranges,
get some bananas and leave me Your Hotel Room.
You know that you're going to ensure that you're going to be taking in fresh
nutrients and it's just a little trip to the supermarket.
It's not that hard.
A lot of times he'll start putting that into the line items and things to get
done.
You know what?
I get to men when I go to a,
I get Kombucha.
I don't have one right here.
Oh,
I know Kombucha.
Oh Dude.
This big for probiotics.
As far as like your immune system health,
it was like one of the best things.
I love it.
It makes a huge impact.
I very,
very,
very rarely get sick and I travel a lot.
I don't get sick lots.
I'm fortunate there.
Knock on wood.
I'm good with that,
but I just feel I get run down and I put on weight and then I get it in my face
right away.
I'll see pictures when we're on the road.
I'm like,
fuck,
I was eating bad and like my face gets pudge,
Ese and brain inflammation too.
It sugar.
Well that's what you're crushing energy drinks and all that crap.
So those are acid in a can.
Like you can feel like when you burp him up and stuff,
you're like,
that is acid.
I'm surprised it doesn't just eat through my stomach and leak out of my belly
button.
I'll tell you what though.
Red Bull is fucking delicious.
It is delicious.
I just assholes.
Red Bull to make it so yummy.
I'm with a taste.
I like the taste too.
It's cool.
I crushed
those on like when we go on the road,
we actually had a joke.
We had our sound guy when we were filming the culture.
I came in our van and he's like,
why is your fence smell like red bull?
And we're like,
look at all the cans and the that we're crushing red bull and we're like,
that's why it smells like red bull.
That's tough.
It's super bad for you though.
So bad.
Especially when you drink those big ones like gas station,
you don't want to ever go.
I've,
I've really been good at that.
That I don't ever drink more than two of the small sugar free.
That's the most I drank back in.
Then when we were working in the called,
there's days I drank like four or five like giving myself.
That's really scary.
Yeah.
Well the,
there's a gas station and then I go to the sells them and they have the normal
size ones,
but then they have these giant like what the fuck doesn't look like a heart
attack and it can to me I'm scared.
Do they say more than one portion on it?
When you read the giant ones,
does it say like three servings or something?
Sneaky.
I thought it said that on the small ones,
like do not drink more than one can per day and then now you have those giant
bullets.
When I'm like,
they just get,
if they give it to you and just write somewhere in the fine print,
there's four servings per can.
You know,
like they're good.
Yeah,
they're good kids.
They'll say like one serving is 200 milligrams of caffeine,
four servings per camp.
Wait a minute.
How Paul?
Hold on.
How much do you drink before you dick explodes?
How much do you drink before you fucking head oozes out of your ears?
I always wonder when I see someone that's really overweight and they're crushing
one of those giant,
I'm like,
man,
you're,
you're putting your heart at risk.
I'd have to think like that.
Yeah.
I had a friend who used to carry one of those monster energy drinks with them.
You literally never saw him without one of those things.
He was completely addicted to the Muse,
drinking them all day long and he went,
he went to a spin class and he went to spin class with my friend and he was
fucking dying and it's been like,
he literally had to get off the bike,
like his heart was pounding.
I'm like,
dude,
you're on speed speed.
You probably taking a thousand milligrams of caffeine in the last few hours.
We'll since there's been no regulate or there's some regular,
but you've been hearing about a young kids and stuff on sports teams having big
problems.
Right.
Or the five hour energies and stuff.
Killing people there.
Five hour energies kill people.
Well,
I thought that was luck,
but some people when they're studying or something like that,
they crush four or five,
right?
I'm pretty sure five hour energy drink is low caffeine and it's like vitamin B
12 and double check that Jamie Google and see if there is to make sure I'm not
speaking out of my ass,
but I thought I'd read some articles on that if people that,
you know they were looking at the cause of death and it was like really high
caffeine levels or,
or what's the like Grana seat or mal hung that's in a lot of those things were
on a,
on a seed.
So yeah,
that's a natural form of caffeine,
right?
Isn't it?
Or a same sort of similar,
it's like a mixture of them that they would put in because when a federal and
with like was taken out of a lot of them than the Phaedra.
Did you ever have ripped fuel?
We'll try that.
My good buddy of mine who's a big fan and he'd love a show up.
My buddy Jared was addicted to,
we joke about it like in the morning,
I'd hear him cause we roomed in New York and I'd hear the Chicka Chicka Chicka
of bottle and he would take the
ephedra like a daily routine.
Okay,
so look at this.
The extra has 230 milligrams of caffeine.
The regular one has 200 and deek.
What does DECAF,
the five
year,
so how much does that compare it to?
A Cup of coffee?
I think 200 milligrams is a Starbucks large like a Venti Starbucks I think.
Right for Google that find that out.
But then what's the other stuff in it too?
Right?
Like is there like a mixture if you do a lot of the caffeine and a sodium
vitamin B,
12 large p 12 while we have that 8333% of the daily value.
So 500 mcgs of a B 12 fold account.
What'd you do?
Oh that kind of shows a comparison there.
The Red Bulls and stuff like that.
Niacin,
which is healthy for you.
Energy blend.
Look at this though.
What does that energy blend?
Where do you see that?
Right there at the bottom,
taurine,
which is funky with Heidi said that glue co glucuronic acid,
malic acid,
a couple different um,
amino acids.
Caffeine though.
So there's more caffeine on top of it.
And the energy blend,
right?
Or is that blend where the caffeine comes from?
I guess the caffeine comes from that blind.
Yeah.
So what is,
um,
what is,
in the US car?
One is like,
oh two and a half cup.
Notice how they have Dunkin donuts coffee.
Not Tim Horton was.
So one of those is two and a half cans of fucking bread bowl.
See?
So that's what I think the articles I saw,
Whoa,
I'm totally wrong on this because the commercials would say that it's the same
as a cup of coffee.
Whoa.
That's weird.
They,
I thought they were seeing that,
you know,
and again,
it goes to that abuse thing.
Just some people are overloading when they were doing schooling.
They're crushing like five and then they find it.
Yeah,
that's a shot.
I mean it's like,
it's easy to do two or three of those.
So if you do four or five in a row,
yeah.
You're taking a thousand milligrams of caffeine.
I had no idea.
I thought it would for some reason I thought it was like 65 milligrams.
Okay.
Red Bull Rockstar.
Where's the coffee?
Well,
just find out where the Starbucks is.
Find out what Starbucks coffee is.
Um,
I think that a red line was like a really scary one.
Do you ever have one of those around more?
I drank a half of one of those wants and I read and it was one of those several
servings per can.
Lot of big can either,
but it was like,
whoa.
Actually had a day in one of our shoots,
right.
I'd had too much,
uh,
energy drinks and the next day I actually felt like I was really hung over 16
ounces.
330 milligrams Po what?
Hmm.
Find out if that's universally true because,
well,
what's that one up?
There were numbers.
What's that?
Three 34 15 for the venti.
Oh my goodness.
To
60.
For a tall.
That's incredible.
Wow.
That is crazy.
A tall has 260 milligrams,
but you know,
here's the other thing.
If you get like a coffee from a diner,
like a regular cup of coffee,
it's way less than that.
Yeah.
55 yeah.
Eight ounce.
Yeah.
Well what does it
does?
DECAF.
The 55 one 23 eight ounce.
Yeah.
Okay.
Eight ounce brewed cup of coffee from a regular,
you know,
place is somewhere in the neighborhood of 133 if it's instant coffee,
it's 93 that's a big difference.
One 33 and two 60 fucking amen.
And three 30 for a venti.
That's insane.
That's a lot of God recommended daily limits.
So yeah.
So if you had a,
you know,
400 is supposed to be the daily limit and if you have students doing four or
five of those five hour energies,
right,
you're going up to thousand,
you're putting yourself at risky levels and it's so easy to do the shot done.
It's all energy.
Things are weird,
man,
because there's so prevalent.
We're always looking for that boost.
That little pick me up,
but we don't want to take pills.
Pills are bad drink.
But like you said,
I'm like if I give myself a treat now,
cause I try not to have energy drinks on the weekend,
I'll be like,
oh I have a sugar free red bull and a snickers.
Right?
Like I'll go get you a little crazy.
I get crazy because,
uh,
well the kids are eating sugar all fucking day long.
So I get jealous cause I did you let your kids eat sugar all the time?
Like not all the time,
but there's no,
well they get into it.
My boy is such a little Ninja.
We put all the candy aisle like way high to where I have to reach up.
It's on.
And that guy,
he pushes the goddamn stools in.
It's in a Pantry,
opens the door,
pushes it up,
and he'll get up there and reach up the licorice.
And then we'd come down and were like,
hey,
where'd you get that?
And he's like,
from the pantry.
Like,
how old is he?
Three.
How about you keep an eye on you?
Three year old.
You fucking Jesus Christ.
Just letting them wander.
Well,
what about the knives?
Let him pick up the,
where'd you get the gun son?
What?
Oh,
found it.
Don't we just let them play with a butcher's knife?
It's not the other one.
So
yeah,
it's um,
the sugar thing is a big draw for kids,
man.
It's crazy when you see you like my daughter had a party recently and uh,
when it came time to cut the cake until his little mother fuckers come over with
a glazed look like you're asking me.
I have a big piece.
Yeah.
Have a whipped cream all the way cream.
A little crazy little eyes.
Crazy sugar eyes.
It's just weird.
Like you're giving them a drug,
you know,
delicious drug fucking cake's awesome.
I'm not,
I'm not anti cake,
but I'm just saying there's something weird about seeing like little five year
olds all glassy eyed lining up to get k and it's all they like.
I mean we're really big and then you know,
fit in.
Our kids are pretty good.
Like they eat fish and they eat vegetables,
but they always want like,
I mean when it time for candidates suites is what they're pushing for all the
time.
It's really unnatural.
The concentration of processed sugar in our foods is so unnatural and the body's
just not designed for it.
And the rush that it gets for it,
you know for that it's your body wants to recreate that rush.
Like kids fucking love it.
Like if I'm a kid that doesn't love candy now,
they all love it.
It's just,
it's gross.
And there's probably a documentary in that.
There I that's,
it's an interesting one that gives a lot of times when people will,
there's not too many that come and try to like debate me on Twitter and stuff.
They don't last very long.
If they do and they tried to bring up wiki stupid arguments like,
well you're going to be as marijuana.
And I was like,
yeah,
you shut up.
You can have used just about anything.
That's a silly argument.
So stupid.
Those arguments are so they're,
they're mind numbing to me.
Like the Nancy Grace One,
I mean there's a,
there's a picture of me and Nancy Gray side by side with Nancy grace talking
about how it makes you fat.
We posted that and it got like some of the more like 14,000 likes or something
like that.
It's the whole thing is silly.
If you are a lazy person,
you're going to be a lazy person.
It's that simple.
Even a person who's like really fit and healthy might occasionally like tying
one on with their friends.
It's fun.
Sometimes it's just moderation.
You know,
there's,
there's plenty of things that you can do that aren't necessarily healthy if you
do them all the time.
But there you're not going to really pay.
The price is a thing that is to say he did,
but this was the thing that came up with that,
you know,
the law enforced me interviewed is that if the whole idea when you hear the
other side is to reduce harm,
right?
If that's what they're selling you on.
Like,
look,
we can't allow marijuana cause we're going to reduce harm.
Harming somebody further with a criminal record,
take away their right to education,
preventing them from job opportunities and preventing them from traveling is far
more harmful than not only just marijuana,
but a lot of other illegal drugs too because statistics show even the most
addictive drugs.
It's like,
I think even heroin,
the highest is like 30% like it's a lot of people have used drugs and then don't
continue to abuse them.
Well,
it's kind of a false narrative though really,
because no one is really trying to protect anyone.
They're just trying to utilize the clause in the law that allows them to
imprison you.
Yeah,
that's really what it is.
And they,
they get people to fill their prison.
They get people to go through their legal system,
so they validate the legal system,
they validate the amount of police officers that they need.
They validate the amount of prison space they need and it all feeds into this
business,
which was also,
you guys talked about in the culture,
high,
big on the law enforcement part is a lot of people's favor as well because it's
terrifying when you realize that there's so much momentum behind that and
there's so much,
they have so much motivation to keep those laws in place so they can continue
arresting people because if they don't,
that industry implodes.
50% of the law enforcement and the arrest in this country have to do with
nonviolent crimes that involve drugs.
It's a skate like ed burns who closes the film,
right?
That was a cocreator of HBO is the wire.
He's the cop that you see throughout the film.
That's like he's scary when you sit down with him and he breaks it down how it
is.
Right.
And when you think about seizures of assets and stuff,
like you don't get to do that for murderers and rapists,
although you should.
So their incentivize like murderers and rapists fall below as far as pro profit
incentive for precincts because they don't get to take their money.
Good asset for,
for drugs.
They do crazy crazy.
Like if you're a murderer or a rapist,
they can't take your TV.
Yeah.
But if you got to like a roll of joints in a plastic bag,
boom,
they just come in and start taking your shit and sell shit.
It's just,
there's just so many bad laws that are in place.
It's almost overwhelming.
And I think for a lot of people we get really frustrated because it seems like
there's,
you can't fix it all.
Like I'm 47 I'll be 48 in August,
which means I'm almost 50 I'm,
you know,
I'm a fucking middle aged man at if I'm lucky,
I'm a middle aged man,
I'm a grown up,
100% grown up.
Right.
This is as grown up as you get.
And yet I'm still immersed in this system that has been in this position or
similar position since I was a child.
Very little has changed,
you know?
So there's been some movement towards sanity and clarity and legalization and
freedom,
but there's still this asset forfeiture thing that guy with the convenience
store that are stealing his money and you know the numbers that they've posted
of a asset forfeiture takeovers over the last year or two.
It's staggering.
And it's unfucking believable how much money it is and the murder conviction
rate that we brought up in the film.
How was actually higher earlier because the cops say one of the biggest things
is that resources,
we no longer have communication with the community so we can no longer prevent
the crimes.
Even with all our technology,
forensics,
DNA,
everything else,
murder,
conviction rates have gone drastically down.
Yeah,
they've turned cops essentially into glorified revenue collectors.
That's what they've done.
I mean,
could you imagine this is,
we were talking about this once.
Could you imagine if they made soldiers write tickets in Afghanistan,
you know,
you match of soldiers had a quota and they had to get money from the Taliban.
Hey,
you fucks.
Sorry,
I saw you making an IED.
You're doing court on Tuesday and here's your piece of paper.
Like the,
no,
no.
Soldiers are over there doing soldier type shit.
Will cop should be doing cop type shit.
Okay.
It should be arresting people for committing dangerous crimes that that put us
all in in harms way.
We'll even,
Sean done again,
who's the former DEA analyst that we interviewed him.
He talked about his dad who was a beat cop in New York and he said when his dad
went to work,
it was like a sports coat.
His shirt,
his badge,
his gun.
He's like,
and that's how we work the beat.
now it's military boots and he sings.
He's like,
how do you,
how does the community feel like you're part of the community when you're
dressed like a soldier?
Like right away,
you know,
impressions and stuff.
That all matters,
right?
Like you don't feel,
communities don't feel welcome when that comes in.
If he was like,
there's a major problem,
but if a beat cops got a sports coat and his bulletproof vest underneath his
dress shirt and he's working to be like,
hey,
like look,
there's a missing girl.
Has there been anything suspicious?
Well,
there's a house on the end of the street,
but when military soldiers come up,
you're like Kinda like,
Whoa,
are you going to come raid my house or you're going to come beat us up?
Right?
Like it's not where a community wants to welcome them and considers them part of
the community.
I think it also does something for the mentality of the people that are wearing
the military garb to absolutely up in a tank.
You're going to have a totally different attitude then you step out of a fucking
Crown Victoria.
Exactly.
That.
Were those things called those police cars ltd crown Victorias I would.
Those things are,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's like
police officers should be respected and appreciated members of the community
that you call upon when the shit hits the fan and when you put them in a
position where they were arresting people for pot or where you put them in a
position where they're being forced in these asset forfeiture situations.
Even giving them the license to do.
That becomes problematic because when you tell someone it's okay for them to do
it,
then they don't even have the opportunity to go,
well,
hey,
you know morally is this right?
Well it doesn't matter if it's right.
That's the job.
The job is take the money,
arrest the guy.
Like that's the job.
That's agenda.
You become used to that job and it becomes fuck them and then it becomes us
versus them though.
That attitude is the worst aspect of the relationship between law enforcement
and civilians and we need law enforcement.
You know we've talked about this,
a situation that happened in Baltimore where an rt reporter was filming these
young kids.
They were jumping around and saying a bunch of Shit and then one of the kids
takes her fucking purse and runs and she's chasing after him.
Give me my purse back in that bag back and she's,
as she's chasing this kid,
a cop grabs the guy,
the cops grabbed the guy and get her purse back.
Like you see like everyone's so down in the cops,
everyone.
So anti law enforcement here is a situation where law enforcement actually did
its duty and it happened in the midst of chaos where law enforcement has failed,
you know,
chaos,
law enforcement killed somebody.
This is huge riots that have come up because of that,
this huge separation between the community and the people that are supposedly
protecting that community and this huge rift.
But then you see like,
oh okay,
like there is a time where law enforcement is not just beneficial but necessary.
I have,
I mean there's no question you need law enforcement.
Yeah.
It's just interesting with like interviewing a lot of these very respect to
police officers and how they really talk about how it was the fundamental
breakdown of dividing them,
making them the enemy,
like the drug war to them.
They just said,
look,
I saw it.
It's separated communities.
It made us look as the other cause.
Look if Joe,
we both have children,
if something happened to them,
you want justice to be done and then if the cops are coming,
like what happened?
Did someone go missing?
Did someone hurt them?
You want that there.
But if that communication is broken and it feels more like now I'm getting
interrogated,
well what did you do?
And they come bullying you and uh,
we found drugs.
Maybe it's your fault that this happened.
It's like,
no,
someone hurt my kids.
Like just focus on them.
Whereas also that's also just dummies that are cops.
The problem is there's not a lot of,
like in Los Angeles they have these fucking billboards trying to get people to
become cops cause nobody wants to be a cop.
You know?
And it's an incredibly tough job.
Like super dangerous,
massively stressful.
The PTSD these guys get,
nobody brings up,
everybody talks about soldier Ptsd and very few people respect the PTSD that
cops have cause they fucking have it.
Man.
You know a,
a friend of mine was telling me about this guy who jumped off of a building and
all these cops were around and they were taking care of the situation.
Then they,
a one cop showed up with donuts and they started handing doughnuts out and these
guys are eating donuts while they're,
you know,
taking witness accounts and dealing with this.
There was so over it,
they're just so over it.
Like they watch this guy splatter and become asphalt pizza,
you know,
jumped off of a building and they're like,
all right another day in the job.
Like ultimately that has got us fuck with your head.
One of my good buddies from high schools become a cop in Canada and he was
talking about some of the first,
like the first dead body you saw with someone that blew their head off with a
shotgun.
They'd use state cause you have to use like a stick in order to reach it or
something.
And then their whole face had caved in and they were the first ones on scene and
the smell.
And I was like,
dude,
I like,
how do you even react that?
He's like,
I just pretend it's like a video game,
right?
Like I just,
I have to kind of zone out and wait for the cleanup crew.
And I couldn't imagine seeing that even once a year if you had to come up on
that kind of stuff.
Like right.
And they're seeing it all the time and everybody they run into on a daily basis
is either lying to them or nervous about meeting them or is hiding something or
you know,
it's just fuck man.
I mean it's a terrible job.
It's really hard to do and made way worse by the drug war.
Way Worse Way,
way,
way worse that that fucking scenario where those guys and when it starts out
your film,
when those guys shoot that dog like that just should show you right away.
We're talking about pot.
We're not talking about anything that's going to hurt anybody.
And because of that,
these guys felt like they had the writing on the paper that allowed them to go
in there and shoot a dog and scare the fuck out of break into your house at
three in the morning with your kids in the house and shoot your until hog.
Meanwhile,
if that was handled better,
I mean it would be a comfortable liquid.
He got in there.
It was a pipe.
Okay,
well throw this out.
Give you a citation.
I mean,
do they even give you a citation when you have a pipe?
within to do,
you're going to write them up,
make them go to court or something.
Okay.
Just don't shoot this fucking dog.
Like the whole thing is just,
it's,
it's insanity.
It's insanity on an almost like a fictional level.
Like it,
it seems like it's fiction.
Like it's a work of like,
it's some crazy George Orwell book from,
you know,
the olden days before we,
uh,
before we figured out how to live life.
But we haven't figured out how to live life.
We haven't figured out that if there's anything I've learned,
we haven't figured out shit.
But don't you think that because of like these kind of conversations and because
of the Internet and you know,
the backlash that all these archaic drug laws and drug policies have had,
the backlash has been unprecedented.
The amount of people that react to it today as opposed to the way they treated
it in the 80s during the Reagan administration.
It's very,
very different.
I mean,
it's changing all over.
the UK is challenging right now.
Portugal
decriminalized all drugs 10 years ago and had great success.
In fact,
we interviewed one of the scientists that went in research that for a little
bit.
Uh,
Doctor uh,
Julian hurt in the UK and he said everyone that was against them originally
bringing in that bill is now can't believe that they were fighting against it.
Like violent crime has gone down.
They said now we can focus on the heart and criminal criminals and the big
traffickers and less time like,
and the people that have substance abuse,
they've seen teenage use down all these things down,
like all the horror stories you're hearing.
And then Uruguay and Canada's changing policies and us,
every other state seems to be challenging looking for medical legalization or
then full legalization,
like as the end of the film kind of says like the house of cards is collapsing
fast and things like these podcasts and access information and getting the,
even the way we release the film where we put it on Vimeo right away where
everyone in the world could get it.
And then now it's on Netflix in,
I think it's a 70 different countries in 14 different languages,
like you didn't have that years ago,
right?
Like now it's Portuguese.
Dutch.
I see.
It feels great when you work so hard on something,
then you can search,
you know,
on Twitter and we go on there and we'll search the culture high and you'll see
in Dutch and Spanish and Portuguese people saying,
wow,
this changed my mind.
It's amazing.
Like you didn't have,
you weren't able to reach out like that before.
Right.
There's a time and connectivity with podcasts and Internet.
We've talked about this in the film.
You kind of go actually,
like it's changing so quick and you can't bullshit people the way you used to.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's only getting more and more in involved in people's lives.
It's only getting more and more invasive.
And I should,
the word invasive sounds negative,
but the technology has allowed information to get to you so quickly.
It's virtually impossible to lie about facts now.
It's just too hard.
I mean,
we're going to come,
there's gonna come a point in time,
some time in our lives where all this stuff has reached some sort of a boiling
point.
And that boiling point is,
it's,
it's gonna make us look like fools for going through our lives the way we did
like in the eighties and the nineties.
It's going to really make society look like a bunch of monkeys with guns and
badges and re pieces of paper with things written on it.
And,
and then we acted on those.
Like we're,
we're going to look just as ridiculous as the people that were involved in the
inquisition or the people that were burning witches in Salem.
All that's actually,
I don't think they really burned witches.
Do you know that?
That's kind of bullshit.
Then they drown.
They drown them.
It was a lose lose where it was like,
if you don't drown your,
which,
yeah.
And if you do drown,
sorry,
we fucked up.
Do you know what they think was the cause of all that?
Did you ever,
uh,
read into that?
They think it was ergot poisoning or God is a type of fungus that exists in
wheat that has a similar effect to LSD and they believe that it was because of a
late frost and that a lot of wheat got damaged and it causes this fungus to grow
in the wheat.
Like they did some samples,
core samples of the,
the dirt and they found like some certain climatological clues that lead them
to,
to believe that that could have very possibly happened that ergot poisoning in
the week cause people to have these crazy acid like a fax.
And they thought there were bewitched.
It makes perfect sense.
I'd read some of this stuff to where it was some people were having like a
mistresses and stuff like that and it was a way to shut up the lower p like the
common folk.
Yeah.
Just be like,
you're a witch
honey.
I don't know.
I didn't look deep into that.
So maybe,
well,
I'm sure people have done horrible things in the past and uh,
they will continue to do so until we can read minds.
I think that's going to be the big one,
man.
Once we,
once we have some sort of a way to read each other's own mental database.
I've heard Richard Talk about that in the podcast and I agreed so much where
it's just like if he took lying off the table instantly it was like you were
tapped in and it was like as soon as somebody said something,
he was like,
we are all tapped into Google.
Like essentially it was built and he's like,
oh,
he's lying.
Like I've got the information.
That's bullshit.
Right?
Like not only that and you forget about it.
Even information.
How about your own thoughts and feelings?
Like don't be a bully.
Like if you're not a politician or a bullshit artist.
Like if I could see if I could look at you and I see green,
which means everything's groovy and then as soon as it turns yellow up,
Adam might be bullshit.
Yeah,
good.
We went red.
Yeah.
I mean that's not outside of the realm of possibility.
They've already shown that they can tell.
There's certain things that they could read in a person's brain if they're being
deceptive.
And they've even used f MRI in a case in India to convict a woman of a crime
because she had what they call functional knowledge of the crime scene.
And it's very controversial and neuroscientist MRI,
which is functional Mri magnetic resonance imagery and um,
well,
you know,
Mri they have,
if you have an injury and well look at the,
um,
the tissue functional MRI is a type of Mri they use to scan brain activity and
they believe that this is like the baby steps to be able,
being able to actually read the mind definitively.
Like right now they're getting these signals and the signals are very
controversial because some people say,
well,
having a functional knowledge of the crime scene could have been imparted on her
by the case,
by the evidence,
by reviewing the evidence with the lawyers.
Like somehow or another,
they could've imparted this somehow in her mind or you know,
being interrogated or investigated about it.
Um,
but the,
the point being that they're starting to hone in on various aspects of the brain
and various,
like whether or not you're deceptive or nervous or whether or not like,
and who knows what right now this is like the,
this is the Morse Code of mine living in a day as opposed to high speed video on
Vimeo,
which is what we got now.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Think about the difference between just a couple of hundred years ago,
if you were on the other side of the world,
they would have to send a series of fucking BBB,
BBB and technology's accelerating at a pace that we've never seen.
Things are coming out every day and I can't even believe,
I'm like,
like three d printing blows my mind.
I don't know how they're like reprinting ears and like Oregon's like what are
they using as material?
I don't understand that.
I don't,
I don't get how that works.
Well w the Oregon thing is not three d printing with the Oregon thing is that
they're taking tissue samples and stem cells and they're,
they're using skin cells to create new bladders for people.
They,
they built this woman and Esophagus,
she had esophageal cancer and they used a three d printer to make like the
scaffolding for the cells and the cells grew and then should they replaced her
esophagus like fucking bananas.
But the,
I think like the exponential growth of this sort of technology.
If you apply like look at communication,
you apply it to like Morse code to a high speed video that's available streaming
on your phone.
Yeah,
he's amazing leap.
I think that same thing applied to the mind and to understanding the signals of
the mind is gone.
Almost leave us in a position where we have no choice but to be honest and when
we have no choice,
but to be honest,
we're going to live in a different world.
There's going to be no more cults.
Dell,
the whole Scientology thing's going to go out the window.
The Vatican was labs.
While that Shit's going down and it's going to go down just based on information
and truth,
the ability to recognize that someone,
and it's still opinions are still gonna exist,
there's still going to be debate.
You know,
you could,
you could believe what you're saying and be truthful in your opinions.
Then it'll come a matter of the distribution of information disproving you and
getting into and then finding out,
oh well it's purple.
He's self deceptive.
Like this is what's going on.
This guy's got a blockage in.
Yeah.
Cause I mean if that's something that really fascinated going clear is just like
how this guy that seem to have some kind of mental illness.
He was trying to diagnose himself,
like constantly putting him,
how he was able to convince people.
So infallibly to like follow him.
Like where he had them out on a ship and he was hiding and country your shirt.
Yeah.
Look at your shirt.
You see that shirt doesn't chimp.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the problem.
We have chimp DNA still in our system and that it chimp that you're wearing on
your tee shirt.
Chimps that's a big part of our fucking ancestry,
the following Alpha male behavior.
And you know,
ultimately that's archaic.
And ultimately this does need to find someone that it used to be the tribal
leader,
the old gray man with the scars that learned from all of the mistakes and could
impart his wisdom on you and make your life a little bit easier because this
guy's already learned these things and he can he teach me?
I mean,
we all know that we all have had mentor figures when we were growing up as a
person who is older than us,
that perhaps had more wisdom,
more life experience,
and could cut a lot of the learning stages out,
cut a of the pitfalls
that you might experience the trial and error.
And I think that,
you know,
that's,
that's a big part of what's wrong with people as we,
we get scared when we don't have answers.
What about that?
The part that was interesting to me,
that was like how you even had people like,
like Paul Haggis and stuff like,
uh,
caught up in that world.
I was really young though.
You know when you're really young,
you really impressionable and I coulda got sucked into dynamics when I was
younger.
I know I could of the beginning parts of it are pretty key like you said,
the science and like making well like I was like,
ah,
I can see why I think I got tested like several years ago.
Are they going here?
And like when were you thinking about right there.
And it was like they were trying to hand out pamphlets actually.
Right.
By the way,
where the hotel,
where we're staying there.
Like here,
I was just telling my,
my buddy that came with me trend,
I was like,
that's it.
That's science.
They say like,
do you want to do a personality test?
Right?
Like that's how it starts,
right?
Come on the little,
I did one in 2008,
2007 2008 and uh,
you know,
he held onto the cans like the whole thing and the,
the,
the read the meter.
But the guy who was doing it with me,
it was like kind of depressed who's very like low enthusiasm.
It wasn't pitching it very well at all.
He's just a bummed out dude.
And you could tell like,
he just really wasn't into,
we give a shit.
It was weird.
It was just,
he kinda had to do,
he was only going to pay 25 cents or whatever.
Like the slate.
Yeah.
The sea or grind that they get insanely low.
You know,
I went on a,
like a youtube watching binge after I watched that documentary and that David
Miscavige,
whatever the guy's name is,
his,
his own niece wrote a book about him and you know,
she was one of the people that was in the sea org in like,
there's this,
yeah,
she,
we got interviewed by,
what's that fuckheads name from England that was whoa.
Took over for Larry King for a while,
for the outset.
Um,
peers,
all warriors,
Morgan.
Um,
she,
uh,
um,
was on his show and just talking about the ridiculous existence that they lived,
you know,
Ma maintaining all these different properties and all these different things
essentially through slave labor by all their employees and how they discourage
them from having children.
And they would try to get them to have abortions and just like,
oh,
is awful.
It was the thing that scared me the most about it too is that I could really see
a lot of similarities to other ideologies and the way that it managed its way
like it almost like it's a virus when you learn requirement based selling,
right.
I used to come from a sales background.
There's a way that humans can,
you find their business motives and buying objectives and you can kind of circle
around and get them emotional buys.
There's ways to just humans kind of react.
Right?
You get them excited.
Well does this bug you about your business or when you like a solution to that,
yes,
I would like a solution to that.
Right,
and then you can and that you'd see the similarities.
When I was watching that like yes,
I didn't tell Jean that movie freak me out,
but I was like,
man,
I could see how so many others would get you looped into that.
Right?
Like make you feel good and then make you feel part of a team and then suck you
in on this and give up your money.
It the whole thing freaked me out.
I thought Alex gave me,
he did great.
He's the top dog for docs right now.
Like Alex give me as the guy that as a documentary filmmaker we look up to like
he's the one that we definitely did a great job with that documentary,
but the,
the Scientologists are hounding him now.
Ne What do they do?
Like how they hounding and what does it,
what can they do?
I don't know,
other than she just watch it and go,
maybe we're crazy.
I smoke a joint,
wash that shit and go,
God,
what are we doing?
What are we doing?
This guy was nuts.
Maybe we can change it a little bit and make it better.
Right.
When we see Tom Cruise Salute Lrh we did it her way.
Like,
Oh,
I really fucking scary marrying.
I love saluting him.
Like he's like an apostle like this.
We've done even better.
It's like he's military and then he'd get,
they give him that.
He's all excited like,
yes,
here's my metal.
Metal is like a fucking flavor flave clock one they just created for him.
It wasn't even according to the film.
It wasn't even something that was there before.
They just wanted,
what's his name that Miscavige created it to be like to kind of bring them back
in.
Like you're getting this metal that like nobody else gets this amazing.
It's really beautiful.
And if you a fan of human folly,
like I'm a big fan of folly.
I love when people fuck up.
I just,
not necessarily that I want people to fuck up.
I just love,
I love like clear,
undeniable craziness like that kind of stuff.
Like seeing Tom Cruise,
standing on a podium with this fucking gold metal,
talking to that guy saying,
I've never met a man more honorable,
more noble,
or in saluting.
We tell on h we did it as I was watching,
it almost seemed like a movie clip to me.
Like he was in character.
I was watching it being like,
this is real.
They like it really had this,
this wasn't,
that guy's amazing.
Tom Cruise's.
Amazing.
Amazing in that he's just so,
first of all,
brilliant actor,
but just so Goddamn wacky off the charts wacky,
but you've covered that perfect on the podcast.
I couldn't agree more where when you become really famous world,
famous to where like you know,
nine out of 10 people know your name and you just have yes.
How about her tenant at the time,
Tom Cruise?
It might be like,
it might be more than I'd be nine 9.8 it's like 999 out of 100 at the very
least,
right?
Yeah,
I would say so.
You just have nothing but yes.
Men saying everything you did.
Like you come up with an idea that's clearly crazy as you're saying,
a ridiculous,
but everyone around you doesn't want to get you upset or get fired,
so they're like,
no,
no.
That's great.
That's brilliant.
You can save the world.
You are when you like a Tom cruise and you're like literally 999 out of a
thousand people know who the fuck you are.
Like Wah,
Wah.
It's probably more than that,
right?
Do we think it's more than that?
I would say out of 100,000 people,
three don't know Tom Cruises.
I would really be willing to sign that.
I'd put money on that.
Then maybe 10 maybe 10 and maybe little kids,
but adults from 18 on let's go from 18 it's like so close to 100% know who he
is.
Yeah,
it's so close I think.
Well you know I had dom on the podcast has,
he's friends with Cher and he used to open up for share all the time and share
without,
she's been famous since she was 19 and she would ask him questions like,
what's it like out there?
What's low?
What's it like?
What do people like like well what's it like to go to the movies?
And he like made her like come out with them in Montreal.
He's like,
what'd he say?
He said,
leave the top hat and cane at home and just call it outside.
And then she's just so weirded out by people because she's been famous for so
long that she's completely alienated and I think Tom Cruise is very similar that
he's been a movie star since the wanderers.
Like what year was that?
The outsiders?
Outsiders.
That's like 81 or something like that,
I want to say and made something incredibly long ago.
What was it,
83 three so a 1983 he's been a fucking huge star since,
I mean that's insane.
It says 32 years,
is that right?
How was that possible?
32 years.
It looks exactly the same.
He's a fucking vampire.
That's what he,
he's in good shape.
How old is he?
He's like 51 or something.
It looks great.
It looks a little worn out in the Cameron Diaz movie,
but do a movie with Cameron Diaz.
How?
See how you turn out?
52 hands of bastard,
but look at this
in with the fucking metal with a giant.
The giant sign.
The glow behind them.
What's what?
All of them.
I don't get what's with all of them wearing like the military outfits,
like with the badges,
like they won,
they went to war.
They,
their word against Xenu,
they'd beat Xenu.
Oh,
oh fuck.
Oh look,
how's he knew
I just,
I,
I'm a,
it's just a really big fan of wacky people like that.
They're so over the top,
but yet so undeniably successful and so brilliant at what they do.
What's that movie tomorrow?
The day after tomorrow.
The edge of tomorrow.
Edge of tomorrow.
Is that what it is?
I really loved that movie.
So the recent recent side of science fiction movie bombed only.
I thought it was a bomb rates.
Yeah,
they didn't do well.
Really?
Yeah.
It didn't make probably all of his wackiness the wackiness is probably catching
up.
Oh,
I think so.
I mean,
it might've,
I'd heard that just it's opening month was not good.
Right.
They were not what they are expecting.
But when you watch a movie,
I agree.
I like,
really,
I remember thinking that was one of the best movies that came out that summer.
It was a really good story.
Is Very unique,
the way the aliens was very different.
And like the concept of redoing the day,
I thought it was great.
I really know.
Did it not do well?
Well,
I know he experienced a big drop in his popularity or the p the way people
respected him after he did that dot.
That a interview with Blackpearl hour.
I thought it was the Oprah went crazy on the couch.
Chicks loved that and I'm in love.
Please.
Yeah,
that was not,
that was not how it man ever behaves when he's in love ever.
That is a guy who loves Dick Italian to be in love with a chick and he's got a
whole team of people covering up for the fact that he loves Dick.
But um,
no,
he did that.
Matt Lauer one where he's getting on Brooke.
Brooke shields for being on antidepressants.
That's right.
You can just correct it with exercise and when you can help it.
But I mean,
the idea that you,
you understand what's going on in her brain,
like,
I'm sorry,
dude,
what kind of research have you done?
Yeah.
Especially what kind of tests have you run it on?
Brooke in particular,
but he's gone but he's cold trickle so he knows what's up.
Right.
It's cold.
Trickle days was under cold Turkey.
I don't know how you remember that.
I remember him from top gun.
That is a big one too.
All right,
Adam scores.
We're out of time dude.
But uh,
thank you very much for doing this.
Thank you very much.
Are you putting together two fucking amazing documentaries?
The union and the culture high has been a real honor and a pleasure to be in
those Joe.
No,
appreciate it.
Thank you man.
Like not just for being a part of those and dedicating your time,
but you know,
always promoting and helping.
You've really helped our careers so I can't thank you enough for,
I'm happier around dude.
Keep doing what you're doing.
I'm going to try and cold shit trouble.
Have you back on again?
You can find Adam score g online.
What is your Twitter handle again?
Adam score with a g like score,
like a goal cause that's how my name is pronounced.
And there's also the culture high,
one word,
which is available also.
Uh,
uh,
it's a,
the Twitter handle and it's available right now on iTunes.
It's available on Prime Google plus basically any platform and it's on Netflix
international and 70 countries in 14 different languages and is fucking
excellent.
It is really excellent.
Thank you my brother.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate it Joe.
Alright,
you fucks.
That's it for this week.
We'll see you next week.
Much love big kisses.
Newman one,
one,
one.
Yeah.